Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der ESA und dem DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das ist jetzt hier mittlerweile die fünfte Ausgabe in dieser Serie von Gesprächen, wo wir eintauchen wollen in die Wissenschaft und vor allem auch ganz konkret in die Praxis der Raumfahrt. Die heutige Ausgabe wird sich allerdings sehr viel mehr im eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Bereich bewegen. Heute wollen wir hier die Frage stellen nach der Entstehung von Planeten, dem Wesen von Planeten und damit auch der Entstehung von Leben und auch dem Wesen von Leben. Und ich begrüße dazu als Gesprächspartner für die heutige Ausgabe Ulrich, Ulrich Köhler.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Vom Institut für Planetenforschung des DLR hier in Berlin, meine Heimatstadt. Diesmal hat es nicht so weit. In Adlershof, was ja ein riesiger Wissenschafts-Campus ist. Wie weit hat sich die DLR hier ausgebreitet? Was ist hier alles noch untergebracht?
Ja, wir sind von einer kleinen Einrichtung im DLR mittlerweile zu einer der größeren geworden. Wir haben auch schon über 600 Mitarbeiter inzwischen hier. Neben unserem Institut für Planetenforschung hat sich hier die Verkehrsforschung des DLR breit gemacht. Und zu einem natürlich zukunftsträchtigen Forschungszweig entwickelt. Es sind noch mehrere kleinere Einrichtungen des DLR hier angesiedelt. Abteilungen des Instituts für Robotik und Mechatronik, Kamera- und Sensorenentwicklungen, Projektträger, all diese Dinge. Und natürlich eine kleine, leistungsstarke, effiziente Verwaltung, ohne die auch die beste Forschung nicht funktionieren würde.
Aber das Institut für Planetenforschung ist jetzt auch nicht das einzige raumfahrtorientierte Institut?
Doch, das ist es. Das ist das Institut, das hier die meiste Grundlagenforschung betreibt und sich hauptsächlich mit dem Weltraum beschäftigt. Wir entwickeln ja keine Raketen. We are not rocket scientists, aber wir machen eben Grundlagenforschung hier und die anderen Institute machen auf dem Gebiet jetzt hier nichts.
Aber man fühlt sich jetzt hier auch nicht isoliert?
Nein, keineswegs. Natürlich vor allem auch deswegen, weil viele unserer Wissenschaftler durch Professuren Kontakt zu den örtlichen Universitäten haben. Also hauptsächlich an der Freien Universität, an der Technischen Universität, aber auch an Universitäten anderswo in Deutschland, wie in Münster, in Dresden oder sogar eben auch in Paris, in Dublin jetzt demnächst. Das wird Alan Harris sein, mit dem wir auch noch einen Podcast machen werden. Und so haben wir natürlich schon einen Kontakt zur Außenwelt.
Also der Wissenschaftsstandort Berlin funktioniert an der Stelle auch gut?
Ausgezeichnet sogar. Also wenn ich mich zurück erinnere, ich war zum ersten Mal hier in den 90er Jahren, vor ein paar Jahren am DLR. Dann war ich zwei Jahre in den USA, aber seither hat sich hier unheimlich viel entwickelt. Und das ist vielleicht auch ganz erwähnenswert. Das ist einer von vielleicht nicht allzu vielen Standorten in Ostdeutschland, wo heute mehr Leute arbeiten als noch vor der Wende. Und das ist eine richtige Erfolgsgeschichte. Und das wird auch immer intensiver hier, weil im nächsten kommt der neue Großflughafen hier in der Nähe. Den lieben zwar nicht alle, aber das heißt natürlich, dass es für Forschungseinrichtungen und Hochtechnologie-Einrichtungen, die es hier ja auch hat, natürlich noch attraktiver wird, sich hier anzusiedeln. Und so arg viel freie Flächen hat es hier ja gar nicht mehr. Und der Standort hat natürlich ganz enorm davon profitiert, dass auch die Humboldt-Universität mit einigen Fakultäten jetzt hier rausgekommen ist. Also es belebt sich so richtig in den letzten Jahren viele junge Leute und macht total Spaß hier zu arbeiten.
Was ist denn so dein eigener Weg in diese Richtung gewesen?
Ja, das mag man gar nicht erzählen. Das ist ein richtiger Klassiker von Menschen, die in den 60er-Jahren geboren sind. Und dann an einem Juliabend im Jahr 1969 wurden die Eltern aus dem Bett gezerrt. Vor einem schwarz-weiß Fernseher. Und gesagt wird, das musst du dir angucken. Weil wenn du das nicht erlebst, dann hast du eines der wichtigsten Ereignisse dieses Jahrhunderts nicht gesehen. Das war nämlich die Nacht, in der Apollo 11 auf dem Mond landete. Und dann wenige Stunden später, die dann für mich als Sechsjährigen natürlich etwas mühsam waren zu überbrücken, weil es war dann schon weit nach Mitternacht, dann hatten sie mich vom Sofa nochmal aufwecken müssen und dann eben live Zeuge waren, wie Neil Armstrong und Buzz Aldrin aus der Igel-Lande-Fähre auf die Mondoberfläche gestiegen sind. Und das hat mich, ich will mal sagen, ein bisschen auf jeden Fall geprägt und später mit dazu bewogen, in dieser Forschungsrichtung einzusteigen. Ich hatte dann einen ganz normalen Weg eines Wald- und Wiesengeologen, will ich es mal nennen, beschritten, habe in München studiert und mich mit Graniten in Brasilien beschäftigt. Und wäre um ein Haar Goldsucher in Brasilien geworden, da hat aber dann meine frühere Freundin nicht mitmachen wollen, hat gesagt, nee, auf keinen Fall. Goldsucher. Und...
Richtig mit einer Schüssel in der Hand.
Nee, nee, es war also eine große Prospektionsaufgabe von einem Großgrundbesitzer mitten im Urwald von Mato Grosso im Westen von Brasilien, der gesagt hat, er zahlt mir zwei Leibwächter, einen Jeep und zweimal im Monat einen Flug nach Rio de Janeiro, wenn ich ihm seine Ländereien, Kartiere auf Gold vorkomme. Und dort war so eine richtige Bonanza-Stadt mit Leuten, die den Gold ziemlich offen in der Hüfte getragen haben. Und man war zwar damals in einem Alter, wo man gedacht hat, das muss unbedingt sein, so was in seiner Vita zu haben. Aber wie gesagt, meine Frau hat mich, meine spätere Frau hat mich dann auf den richtigen Weg zurückgebracht. Und nachdem in Oberpfaffenhofen, wo das DLR damals mit der kleinen Abteilung für Planetenforschung, damals hieß es noch Planeten-Erkundung, nach Leuten gesucht hat, die für den Vorbeiflug der Raumsonde Galileo am Mond Daten auswerten, Bilder zusammensetzen und die Bilder dann auswerten. Und ein guter Studienfreund von mir, das bereits angefangen hat, hab ich ganz schnell die Krawatte geschnürt, bin dort rausgefahren, hab meine Bewerbung abgegeben und der damalige Abteilungsleiter, später unser erster Institutsdirektor, gesagt hat, machen Sie die Krawatte ab und fangen Sie gleich an.
Super, das heißt, Geologie war sozusagen dann die wissenschaftliche Grundausbildung, die hier zum Tragen kam.
Genau, weil viele Prozesse, die auf zumindest auf den Himmelskörpern mit fester Oberfläche im Sonnensystem sich abspielen, die kennen wir von der Erde, übertragen sie auf die Planeten und Monde des Sonnensystems und leiten daraus unsere Schlüsse ab.
Das heißt, in diesem Institut sind auch viele Geologen unterwegs?
Nicht mehr so viel wie am Anfang, die Mischung ist sehr viel breiter geworden. Am Anfang waren es sehr viele Geologen, die sich mit praktisch klassischen Aufgaben der geologischen Fernerkundung beschäftigt haben, also zunächst einfach Bilder angeschaut haben, diese Bilder ausgewertet haben, kartiert haben, die Krater gezählt haben, die Krater statistisch erfasst haben, um Altersbestimmungen durchzuführen. Dann erste Arbeiten mit moderneren Sensoren, das fing ja dann so in 90er Jahren an, dass man auf die Raumschiffe Multispektralkameras bauen konnte, die also in verschiedenen Wellenlängen die Oberfläche fotografiert haben, im sichtbaren Licht und dann im nahen Infrarot eben auch mit Spektrometern gearbeitet hat, so dass man erste mineralogische Analysen von den Planetenoberflächen machen konnte. So haben sich eben immer mehr neue Fachrichtungen bei uns auch wohlgefühlt. Wir haben seit einigen Jahren eine ganz starke Geophysikkomponente, die modelliert das Innere von Planeten, den Aufbau von Planeten. Wir haben seit kurzem eine ganz tolle Abteilung, die sich mit der Entdeckung von Exoplaneten beschäftigt, also die suchen Planeten an anderen Sternen, untersuchen inzwischen auch Möglichkeiten, wie man sehen kann, ob so ein fremder Planet möglicherweise eine Gashülle hat, die der unseren ähnelt. Also dass man aus dem winzigen Lichtpumpt, den man vielleicht gerade so noch mit einem Sensor erwischen kann, vielleicht schon Schlüsse daraus ziehen kann, ob diese Atmosphäre Gase enthält, die auf Leben hindeuten. Das ist nun mal schon ein Anfang darauf hinzuweisen. Wir haben, was natürlich ganz toll ist, durch den Hochzug von Oberpfaffenhofen hier nach Berlin-Adlershof eine wunderbare Heirat durchgezogen mit dem früheren Institut für Kosmosforschung, das hier von der Ostdeutschen Akademie der Wissenschaften betrieben wurde, die eine ausgezeichnete Instrumentenentwicklung hatten, für die damals vor dem Fall des Eisner Vorhangs sowjetische Raumfahrt eben, für Missionen zu Venus und zu Mars und haben davon sehr stark profitiert, haben auch selber Kameradentwicklungen eingebracht. Wir haben eine wunderbare Abteilung für Planeten-Geo-de-Si, das sind also, wenn man das Böse sagt, einfach Landvermesser, Landvermesser für Planeten, die machen also Karten in allerhöchster Präzision, wie es nicht viele Gruppen auf der Welt können. Atlanten von Eismonten am Saturn und die genauen Höhenmodelle der Mars- Oberfläche. Und so kann man nicht sagen, dass es ein reines Institut für Planetengeologie ist. Die Planetengeologie ist eine von mehreren Abteilungen. Wir haben Forschungen in der Terraherz-Frequenz und alles Mögliche.
Institut für Kosmosforschung, der DDR ist dann sozusagen hier komplett auch in dem DLR-Institut aufgegangen, ein Teil davon geworden.
Es ist ein Teil des Instituts geworden und es wurden, soweit ich mich erinnern kann, auch mehr Arbeitsplätze erhalten, als es bei vielen anderen Einrichtungen der Fall war. Und aus meiner Sicht hat diese Fusion sehr gut geklappt. Es hat natürlich auch Anlaufschwierigkeiten gegeben, wie man miteinander zurechtkommt und das hat aber gerade auf der Ebene der jungen Mitarbeiter ausgezeichnet eigentlich funktioniert und wir haben eine erstklassige Arbeitsatmosphäre hier im Institut schon immer gehabt eigentlich und können vielleicht nicht viele Leute behaupten, dass sie jeden Tag sehr gerne überhaupt zur Arbeit gehen und also für viele von uns trifft das sicher zu, dass sie also jeden Tag gerne da sind, weil wir einfach zurzeit an sehr vielen spannenden Projekten arbeiten.
Und auf welchen Begriff hat man sich geeinigt? Sagt man Universum oder sagt man Kosmos?
Ach, ja richtig, ob es Kosmonoten oder Astronoten sind, jetzt gibt es ja auch noch die Taikonoten, also ich denke mal Weltall ist der neutrale Begriff, den wohl die meisten verwenden.
Gut, Weltall, ja dann schauen wir doch mal hinein ins Weltall. Also ist schon klar geworden, hier geht es um Planeten. Stell ich mir natürlich, ich meine, wenn man jetzt so, ich finde ja Kosmos ehrlich gesagt am besten, aber das ist eine Geschmacksfrage. Also wenn man jetzt ins Weltall schaut, man sieht ja eigentlich erstmal nur Sterne. Habe ich so als Kind eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich verstanden habe, dass das, was irgendwie Licht hat, ja im Prinzip auch alles Sonnen sind, aber nur da kommt irgendwie Licht und das ist ja das, was wir zumindest mit unseren Augen überhaupt erstmal wahrnehmen kann. Und von Planeten sieht man ja erstmal nicht so viel. Aber ganz offensichtlich gibt es welche und die sind im Sonnensystem auch relativ früh aufgefallen, weil sie ja diese merkwürdigen Bahnen über den Himmel ziehen, die sich von den Sternen unterscheiden, weil sie ja die ganze Zeit um unsere Sonne herum rotieren, von daher nicht immer nur auf einer Linie entlang. Wann ist das eigentlich, wann ist man sich dessen gewahr geworden, dass es da sozusagen noch so andere Steine gibt, die da so herumfliegen?
Zunächst mal scheint es ganz offensichtlich so zu sein, dass unsere Vorfahren sehr viel mehr Zeit hatten, nachts mal den Himmel zu beobachten und relativ schnell erkannten, dass es eben neben den Fixsternen, wie man sie eigentlich nicht ganz korrekt bezeichnen sollte, Planeten gibt. Auf Griechisch heißt das eben Wanderer, Wandersterne, die eben vor dem Fixsternhimmel Bewegungen vollführen, die darauf hinweisen, dass eben andere Bahnen haben oder überhaupt Bahnen um die Sonne eben haben. Ich bin nicht ganz sattelfest historisch, würde aber behaupten, dass eben mit den frühen Hochkulturen das auf jeden Fall in eine Form kam, wo man das schon beschrieben hat, wie diese Bahnen sind, wann diese Planeten wiederkehren. Klar, man sieht Millionen oder Tausende von Sterne von der Erde aus, es sind so 6.000, die man sehen kann, 6.000 bis 8.000, aber es gibt eben schon allein mit Venus und Jupiter zwei ganz markante, helle, in Anführungszeichen Sterne, die jedem, der den Nachthimmel beobachtet, sofort auffallen würden. Genauso der Mars mit seiner orangen Farbe lässt sich recht gut unterscheiden, guter gibt es ähnlichfarbige Sterne auch noch. Und dann natürlich unsere europäischen Vorfahren, die Griechen und dann die Ägypter natürlich, im Zweistromland, die haben erste ziemlich präzise Aufzeichnungen gemacht und mich fasziniert eigentlich das unheimlich, mit welcher Präzision unsere Vorfahren schon Umlaufbahnen von Planeten berechnen konnten, die sich nicht wirklich groß von den tatsächlichen Zahlen, die wir heute kennen, unterscheiden. Genauso dann auch erste Berechnungen gemacht wurden, wie weit der Mond von der Erde entfernt sein müsste, wie weit die Sonne entfernt sein könnte. Das waren alles schon Zahlen, die recht nahe an der Realität waren und das ist schon sehr erstaunlich.
Und das ganz ohne Computer.
Richtig.
Aber zunächst einmal, ich meine, man muss sich ja auch erst mal gefragt haben, sie imitieren Licht, aber sie imitieren ja nicht ihr eigenes Licht. Wann wurde dieser Unterschied klar, dass sozusagen die Planeten anders sind als die Sterne und nicht nur einen anderen Weg haben, sondern auch von einer anderen Beschaffenheit sind?
Also endgültig klar wurde sicherlich im Jahre 1610, als Galileo Galilei zum ersten Mal mit einem Fernrohr die Venus auch beobachtet hatte und gesehen hat, dass die Venus Phasen hat und das kann natürlich ein runder, sternförmiger Körper gar nicht haben. Der strahlt ja nach allen Richtungen isotrop sein Licht ab und da war natürlich endgültig klar, dass die Planeten nur das Sonnenlicht reflektieren. Ob das vorher allen auch schon klar war, vermute ich mal schon, also Wissen tue ich es nicht mit Gewissheit, aber dass eben der Mond als bestes Beispiel dadurch, dass er Phasen zeigt, relativ schnell klar gemacht hat, dass es eben Himmelskörper gibt, die das Licht nur reflektieren und nicht selber emittieren. Das dürfte über den Mond dann vermutlich auch auf Planeten wie den Mars oder die Venus und den Jupiter, die man also am besten sehen kann, auch den Saturn natürlich noch schon vorher übertragen worden sein.
Jetzt weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wo ich am besten ansetzen soll. Aber was natürlich für mich immer so die große Frage ist, inwiefern kann man davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich Planeten so selbstverständlich sind, dass also hat jede Sonne Planeten, kann man davon ausgehen oder weiß man, dass es nicht so ist?
Keineswegs. Sehr gute Frage, weil bis vor 20 Jahren stand das überhaupt nicht fest. Erst durch die Entdeckung eines ersten Planeten außerhalb unseres Sonnensystems um einen anderen Stern, das war glaube ich 1995, war klar, dass es auch andere Sternsysteme gibt, die auch Planeten haben. Die Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten haben das einfach nicht zugelassen, dass man die mindestens viereinhalb Lichtjahre entfernten Sterne, die meistens ja viel, viel weiter entfernt, dass man damit Teleskopen auflösen könnte, ob da was drum rum sich bewegt. Erst nachdem man zwei, drei ziemlich pfiffige Beobachtungsmethoden sich ersonnen hat, wie man andere Sterne beobachtet, um herauszubekommen, dass da auch noch Planeten sind, hat man wirklich die Gewissheit. Man hat das natürlich vermutet, weil es gehört schon sehr viel Einbildung dazu zu behaupten, die Erde ist oder das Sonnensystem ist so einmalig, dass es nur hier Planeten hat, die einen Stern umkreisen und allein unsere Galaxie, die Milchstraße, hat Milliarden von Sterne und es gibt Milliarden von Galaxien, also dann kann man relativ einfaches statistisches Spiel betreiben und sagen, es kann gar nicht sein, dass andere Sternsysteme nicht so sind.
Das ist also ein normales Spiel des Universums, aber wie läuft denn das jetzt ab? Ich meine, unsere Sonne ist auch irgendwann mal erst mal entstanden aus der Zusammenballung von Materie. Ist denn der Weg, wie sich ein Planet entwickelt, oder der Weg, wie sich eine Sonne entwickelt, vergleichbar? Weil am Ende ist ja eh alles so mehr oder weniger derselbe Baustoff, der so durch das Universum tapert.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also wenn man die ganze Materie im Universum und sich anschaut, aus was die besteht, dann fällt man zunächst auf, fast alles ist Wasserstoff und Helium, weit über 90 Prozent, das heißt fast alles Gase und da fällt schon mal auf, dass so etwas wie die Erde, wo wir festen Boden unter den Füßen haben, natürlich schon mal die Ausnahme ist. Aber man weiß eben auch, dass im Sonnensystem fast alle Masse in der Sonne konzentriert ist und von dem kleinen Rest, der noch übrig ist, ist wiederum fast alle Masse im Jupiter konzentriert und dann kommt man eben diese Verteilungen schön aufgesplittet und merkt eben, dass dann doch schon noch was übrig ist, aus was sich feste Himmelskörper wie die erdähnlichen Planeten, Merkur, Venus, Erdemond, Mars bilden können. Und nach all dem, was wir heute wissen, läuft das wohl nach dem Schema ab, das schon Kant und Laplace vor 300 Jahren formuliert haben, dass sie einfach vermuteten, dass aufgrund der Gesetze der Schwerkraft sich Materie, also dieses Gas- und Staub-Gemisch irgendwo von einer explodierten Supernova beispielsweise irgendwo in der Galaxie sich aufgrund der Gesetze der Schwerkraft zusammenballt, immer dichter wird, das Große frisst das Kleine, ganz unbarmherzige Natur, je mehr Masse beieinander ist, umso mehr Masse zieht sie auch an und dann sich außenrum eine Scheibe aus Staub und Gas bildet, das ganze Gebilde beginnt zu rotieren.
Eine Scheibe?
Eine Scheibe. Ja, wenn ich einen Teller nehme und so einen chinesischen Artisten, der diese Teller so auf dem Stock drehen lassen kann, in ganz hoher Geschwindigkeit und ich leg, mach ein kleines Häufchen mit ganz feinen Kügelchen auf diesen Teller und der rotiert, dann werden diese Kügelchen immer sich mit der Rotation der Scheibe nach außen bewegen und das ist einfach naturgesetzt, dass es so sein muss, dass es nicht kugelförmig bleibt. Aber im Zentrum dieser rotierenden Scheibe hat sich eben schon eine so große Masse gebildet, was dann später der Stern oder die Sonne wird, verdichtet sich immer mehr und wenn eben eine kritische Masse erreicht wird, dann beginnt ein Fusionsprozess im Inneren dieses Sterns zu zünden, sodass eben aus Wasserstoffatomen schließlich Heliumatome zusammen geschmolzen, zusammen gebacken werden und da wird nach dem einsteinischen Gesetz E gleich M a c Quadrat, das kennen wir ja alle, was es bedeutet, ist eben schlichtweg, dass Masse äquivalent zur Energie ist und da wird eben ein kleines bisschen dieser Masse, die verschmolzen wird, zur Energie umgewandelt und das ist eine so ungeheure Menge, dass wir eben eine Sonne haben, die dann ein ganzes Sonnensystem, ein Planeten-System mit Energie versorgen und beleuchten kann Und eben in ihrem Kern Millionen von Grad heiß ist und an der Oberfläche auch noch 6000 Grad und diese Wärme eben ins All abstrahlt. Die Planeten, die sich dann aus dieser Scheibe bilden, da versteht man tatsächlich noch nicht alles, wie es wirklich funktioniert. Auch ich nicht. Man vermutet eben, dass es in dieser Scheibe zu Unregelmäßigkeiten kommt, zu Dichteunterschieden. Und an diesen Unregelmäßigkeiten fängt Materie an, sich zusammen zu ballen, immer größere Körper, immer größere Körper. Zuerst kleine Kügelchen, die sogenannten Kontrollen, die sich dann zu Kontritten zusammenballen. Dann kommen, sag ich mal, Tennisball, Fußballgroße, Brocken zusammen und dann wird...
Was heißt denn Kontrullen und Kontritten?
Kügelchen heißt es einfach.
Also einfach so kleine Zusammenballungen von Masse.
Genau, die sieht man zum Teil noch, wenn man Meteoriten findet und schneidet die durch, dann sieht man so kugelförmige, millimetergroße Kügelchen. Und das ist so eine Ohrmaterie, weil die Meteoriten fast alle aus dieser Uhrzeit des Sonnensystems noch sind.
Das heißt, um das noch mal kurz klar zu machen, im Prinzip kann man sich die Sonne während sie entstand so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie der Saturn heute rüberkommt. Dass man da so eine Kernmasse hat und drum herum ist so eine Scheibe von Zeug.
Das trifft ganz gut, vermutlich, weil man vermutet auch, dass solche Körper wie Jupiter und Saturn es nicht ganz einfach geschafft haben, zu einer Sonne zu werden. Es gibt ja im Universum sehr viele Doppelsternsysteme, dass also nichts ungewöhnliches ist. Das weiß man auch schon relativ lange, wo sich also zwei fast gleichgroße Körper oder ähnlich große Körper umkreisen und beide strahlen Energie ab. Und beim Jupiter und beim Saturn ist es eben so, dass die Masse nicht ganz gereicht hat, dass die dieses Fusionsfeuer im Zentrum gezündet haben. Aber wir wissen ja vom Jupiter und Saturn, dass die sehr, sehr viele Monde, Trabanten haben, die alle auch in dieser Äquator-Ebene dieser beiden Planeten, den Planeten umkreisen. Also sind das sozusagen Sonnensysteme auch Miniatür. Also vermutlich der gleiche Prozess, der sich bei der Planetenbildung im Großen abgespielt hat, im Sonnensystem, hat sich in kleinerer Form, in ähnlicher Form um den Jupiter und den Saturn und eigentlich auch um den Uranus und Neptun herum abgespielt. Was man nicht weiß bei diesem ganzen Prozess, wie sich Materie aufgrund der Schwerkraft zusammenballt, ist, wie es von den kleinsten Gas- und Staubteilchen zu den ersten richtig nennenswerten Kügelchen kommt. Da ist noch einiges im Verborgenen, weil die reine Anziehungskraft, die reine Gravitationskräfte sind da so schwach bei diesen Mini-Mini-Körperchen, fast schon wie Flöckchen, die dort um die Sonne kreisen. Dass dort möglicherweise auch noch andere naturgesetzene Rolle spielen, beispielsweise van der Waal-Anziehungskräfte, also elektrostatische Prozesse, über die man noch nicht so ganz genau Bescheid weiß, wie sie dann letztendlich dazu führen, dass es dann Kügelchen hat, größere Kügelchen, Fußballgröße. Und dann ist das, wie man es in der Natur oft sagt, ein Runaway-Prozess, dass es dann einfach immer schneller geht. Und alles in dieser Umgebung, dieser ersten Planetenkerne oder Keime, alles zusammenballt sich und die Bahn, um die dieser junge Planet, um die Sonne kreist, praktisch freiräumt von aller Materie. Und letztendlich dann ein Planeten-System entsteht.
Das heißt, der Unterschied zwischen Planeten und Sonnen ist eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so groß, weil aus der Sonne hätte auch mal ein Planet werden können, wenn er es nie geschafft hätte zu zünden und hätte sich dann unter Umständen um irgendwas ganz anderes gekreist, wenn überhaupt.
Nicht ganz. Andersherum wird eher ein Schuh draus, dass man sagt, die ganz großen Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem haben es nicht zur Sonne geschafft. Aber man weiß ja, es gibt kleinere Sonnen, die dann an der Grenze zu Planeten nicht die gleichen Charakteristika haben wie unsere Sonne. Braune Zwerge beispielsweise, die man jetzt auch entdeckt hat, die eben auch um andere, größere Sterne kreisen können.
Aha, okay, die sozusagen für sich dann auch Satellit anderer Sonnen sind, weil sie einfach gar nicht genug Masse haben, um da selber zu herrschen. Aber es kreist ja alles irgendwie um einander, weil auch unser Sonnensystem wiederum eingebettet ist in die Milchstraße im Spiralarm und sich um das Zentrum der Galaxis dreht. Also das Spiel der Gravitation geht da immer weiter mit Galaxien-Klustern etc. Aber bleiben wir mal bei dieser Entstehung. Also ich höre immer Gas, Helium, Wasserstoff und Staub sammeln sich zusammen. Was für ein Staub? Also was muss man sich mit dem Begriff vorstellen?
Na ja, das geht dann praktisch nach der Häufigkeit des Vorhandenseins, der Elemente, wie wir es im Universum haben, was dann eben passiert. Und im Grunde genommen funktioniert das so ähnlich wie bei der Eiskunstläuferin, die ihre Pirouetten auf dem Eis dreht. Nahe am Rotationszentrum, nahe am Massenzentrum eben können sich schwerere Elemente besser halten und werden nicht nach außen getriftet. Und die leichten Elemente, die gasförmigen Elemente driften weiter nach außen. Also wenn ich jetzt auf diesem rotierenden Teller, von dem ich vorhin sprach, eben verschiedene Körnchen von verschiedener Dichte spezifischem Gewicht nehmen würde, dann würden die schweren Eisenkörnchen beispielsweise eben nahe des Zentrums bleiben und sich nicht so weit nach außen treiben lassen. Und die leichten Styroporkükelchen, die würden es nach außen treiben. Und so ähnlich war das eben in unserem Sonnensystem auch. Und deswegen haben wir auch diese markante Zweiteilung im Sonnensystem, dass wir eben schwere, relativ schwere Körper im inneren Sonnensystem haben, die ein hohes, spezifisches Gewicht haben. Also wie beispielsweise der Merkur und die Erde, wo jeder Kubikzentimeter mehr als fünf Gramm wiegt. Im Mittel natürlich immer gerechnet. Und im äußeren Sonnensystem, Jupiter Saturn, wo der Saturn sogar unter einem Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter wiegt. Wo wir also praktisch einen Körper haben, der schon leichter ist als Wasser, als wenn man sich ein riesiges Schwimmbecken vorstellen würde. Dann könnte man den Saturn da rein tauchen und er würde wieder an die Oberfläche hochkommen. Also er würde schwimmen.
Und der Mercury würde untergehen.
Der Mercury würde wie ein Stein in einem Erd wirklich bildlich untergehen. Natürlich die Erde auch, die Venus auch, der Mars auch, der Mond auch.
Um noch mal so ein bisschen zurückzuspulen. Also die Sonne hat quasi diesen Tipping-Point erreicht und hat eben mit der Fusion begonnen. War von daher ein starkes Massezentrum. Hat sich eigentlich alles Mögliche einverleibt, was so da ist. Aber dann eben doch nicht alles. Was, ich meine, gut, jetzt weiß man erst vor kurzem, Planeten haben auch andere Sonnen oder auch andere Sonnen haben auch Planeten. Hätte es auch passieren können, dass die ganze Masse, die sich jetzt in den Planeten unseres Sonnensystems versammelt hat, auch irgendwie noch in die Sonne stürzt und die Sonne dann einfach da so vor sich hin brütet und das war's.
Das ist sicherlich denkbar. Das ist einfach eine Frage der Modellierung der Ausgangsparameter. Da bin ich auch kein Spezialist dafür. Es wird sicherlich so sein, weil sonst wär ja vermutlich jeder Stern ein Sternensystem mit Planeten. Und das ist vermutlich nicht der Fall, nach dem, was wir heute beobachten. Das heißt also, in vielen Fällen wird es sicherlich so sein, dass ein Stern eben einfach alles einverlebt, was in seiner Umgebung ist, tabula rasa macht und einfach vor sich hin strahlt. Und weil eben die Rotation dieser Scheibe aus Staub und Gas, die die Sonne umgab, die junge Protosonne umgab, dass das eben dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Dreimpuls und Drehmoment sich so die Waage halten, dass die Planeten eben nicht in die Sonne stürzen.
Kann man jetzt sagen, dass diese Scheibe im Prinzip als solche noch existiert, eben in Form der Planeten?
Das ist zumindest das, was übrig geblieben ist von der Scheibe. Und wenn wir die Region zwischen Mars und Jupiter betrachten, dann sehen wir da sogar auch noch eine ganze Menge Reste aus dieser Gründerzeit der Planeten. Dort ist nämlich der Asteroidengürtel. Und der Asteroidengürtel hat eine ganze Menge Masse, die sich durchaus zu einem kleinen Planeten verdichten lassen könnte. Der größte Asteroide hat sogar einen Durchmesser von 1000 Kilometer Ceres, wird inzwischen sogar als Zwergplanet bezeichnet. Und vermutlich hat sich nur deswegen dort kein Planet aus dieser Trümmermasse oder aus diesen Resten der ursprünglichen Bausteine des Sonnensystems gebildet, weil der Jupiter mit seiner enormen Schwerkraft diese Bahnen ständig durcheinanderbringt und es einfach nicht zugelassen hat mit seiner Schwerkraft, dass sich dort noch ein weiterer Planeten zwischen Mars und Jupiter bildet.
Ah, verstehe. Der reißt sozusagen immer wieder alles auseinander.
Ja, es ist nicht so ganz klar, ob der Jupiter mehr oder weniger ein Schutzfaktor für die Erde ist oder ob er eher bedeutet, dass er die Erde zusätzlich gefährdet. Weil durch die Schwerkraft-Einflüsse von Jupiter kommen solche Asteroiden immer mal wieder auf Kollisionsbahnen mit Körpern im inneren Sonnensystem. Das heißt, die werden dann aus ihren Orbitalbahnen, die sie eigentlich nie mit Erde oder Mars kreuzen lassen würden, kommen die dann auf einmal ins innere Sonnensystem. Und das kann dann zu einem Zusammenstoß führen, was natürlich dann recht fatal sein kann, wie es vor 65 Millionen Jahren für die Saurier war. Schlechter Tag für die Jungs. Denn der Einschlag war halt so groß, dass die Saurier dann die anschließenden sehr kalten Jahre, Jahrzehnte, vielleicht sogar Jahrtausende nicht überlebt haben und dadurch das Aufkommen der Säugetiere begünstigt haben. Vermutlich ist es schon so, dass der Jupiter dafür sorgt, dass viele dieser Körper eben auf gleichmäßige Bahnen gezwungen werden und die Gefährdung der Erde dadurch geringer ist. Auch saugt der Jupiter viele dieser Körper an, die dann in seinem Gaskörper verschwinden, ganz einfach. Aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass er ab und zu manchmal dafür sorgt, dass so ein Körper auf Kollisionskurs mit der Erde kommt.
Das heißt, das Sonnensystem kann man sich so vorstellen, Sonne und alles, was die Sonne damals als Scheibe umgab, was nicht ausreichend angezogen wurde, um in der Sonne selbst zu verschwinden. Trieb quasi in einem riesigen Ausmaß, also sozusagen dieselbe Distanz, die wir heute auch noch sehen, wenn man jetzt das ganze Sonnensystem nach außen durchexerzieren. Also erst mal diese Gesteinsplaneten, wo die Erde eine davon ist, dann der erste Asteroidenkürtel, dann die Gasplaneten und dann kommt noch ein zweiter Kuipergürtel.
Der Kuipergürtel, der eher ein Kometengürtel ist, aber auch in der Ebene der Planeten sich befindet. Und dann kommt noch ganz weit außen, also kugelförmig, die Sonne umgeben, all die ganzen Querschläger, die sich nicht auf diese Banebene zwingen ließen und das große Kometenreservat des Sonnensystems bilden. Und das dehnt sich wirklich aus, diese ortsche Wolke, wie sie heißt, bis an die Grenze unseres Sonnensystems. Das ist ja in Grunde genommen dadurch definiert, dort wo der Sonnenwind, wo diese energiereiche Strahlung von der Sonne abgestrahlt wird, praktisch auf einen Widerstand durch das interstellare Medium trifft, wo praktisch so eine Bukwelle, zwei Wellen aufeinander prallen, die man natürlich nicht sehen kann, aber messen kann eben, dort ist die Grenze des Sonnensystems, etwa bei 18, 20, 25 Milliarden Kilometer.
Alles in diesem Bereich hat sozusagen die Chance, zum Planeten zu werden, aber es gelingt nicht allen.
Man muss sich vor allem als dynamischen Prozess vorstellen. Auch ein Sonnensystem, man kann nie sagen, das ist jetzt abgeschlossen alles. Natürlich tut sich jetzt seit 3, 4 Milliarden Jahren vergleichsweise sehr viel weniger als in der ersten halben Milliarde Jahre. Also alle Planeten haben sich vor etwa 4,5, 4,5, 4,6 Milliarden Jahren gebildet. Dann am Anfang waren das ziemlich unruhige Zeiten, als sehr viele Urbestandteile des Sonnensystems noch herumflogen und praktisch sehr viel häufiger auf Kollisionskurs mit allen Planeten waren. Also die Einschlagsrate war bestimmt um ein Faktor 10 hoch 5, also 10.000 bis 100.000 Mal höher als heute. Das sehen wir ja auch noch da dran, wenn wir mit einem bloßen Auge oder mit einem Fernglas auf den Mond blicken, sehen wir die ganze Mondvorderseite mit Kratern überdeckt. Auf der Mondrückseite ist es noch intensiver. Und das zeigt uns, dass eben die Zeiten sehr viel ungemütlicher waren in der Frühzeit des Sonnensystems. Wir sehen das auf der Erde nur deshalb nicht mehr, weil die Erde eben auch ein sehr dynamischer Planet ist. Im Grunde genommen das krasse Gegenteil zum Mond, der seine Entwicklung vor dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahren so gut wie abgeschlossen hat. Und dort der Zustand eingefroren ist, wie wir ihn damals hatten. Also alle Krater säen. Bei uns auf der Erde gibt es Plattentektonik, gibt es Wind und Wetter. Das heißt, wenn sich ein Gebirge auftürmt wie die Alpen, dann ist es nach 30 Millionen Jahren auch schon wieder verschwunden. Und deswegen sind auch die Einschlagsspuren der Frühgeschichte der Erde längst verschwunden. Und so ist es eben auch mit dem ganzen Sonnensystem. Es ist ein dynamischer Prozess. Es tut sich jetzt zwar fast nichts mehr, aber natürlich passiert immer noch was. Das sehen wir daran, dass es immer noch Meteoriteneinschläge auf der Erde gibt, kleine, die fallen dann halt als Steinbrocken vom Himmel. Wir sehen eben, wie sich Kometen ins innere Sonnensystem bewegen und in der Sonne verschwinden. Das heißt, da verschwindet dann auch mal wieder etwas Materie. Allerdings sehr viel langsamer und mit einem geringeren Faktor als noch vor drei, vier Milliarden Jahren.
Das heißt, das Sonnensystem ist sozusagen weitgehend bereinigt vom Staub und von kleinsten Elementen. Das gibt sie noch, aber entweder haben sie alle so ihren Ort gefunden oder sie sind in irgendeinem größeren Objekt verschwunden.
Richtig, ja. Oder sie kommen eben, werden doch immer noch gestört vom Jupiter und fliegen doch nochmal ins innere Sonnensystem. Aber wirklich für menschliche Maßstäbe, also eine Lebensspanne 100 Jahre, ist es doch relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass man von einem Asteroiden erschlagen wird und einem der Himmel auf den Kopf fällt, wie das bei Asterix immer wieder prophezeit wurde. Aber es wird wieder stattfinden, ganz sicher.
Merkur, Venus, Erde, Mars. Das sind jetzt diese vier, die anders sind als die anderen. Die anderen sind mehr sonnenartig. Dadurch, dass durch die Gravitation die leichten Elemente nach außen getragen werden, ergibt sich, dass die Gasplaneten außen sind.
Auch durch die Temperatur bedingt. In der Nähe der Sonne herrschen höhere Temperaturen. Dadurch haben gasförmige Elemente schwieriger, in eine feste Phase zu wechseln. Beispielsweise Wasserdampf. Deswegen haben wir im äußeren Sonnensystem um die großen Planeten viele Eismonde, wo Wasser bei minus 160 bis minus 220 Grad Celsius feste stabile Eisoberflächen bilden kann. Dort sind praktisch die Planeten des inneren Sonnensystems, die erdähnlichen Planeten, mit gewissen Einschränkungen auf das äußere Sonnensystem übertragen. Dass dort die Satelliten der vier großen Planeten auch wiederum...
Das heißt, die Monde der großen Gasplaneten ähneln wiederum der Erde bzw. den inneren Planeten.
In gewissen Grenzen, ja.
Weil die feste Stoffe an sich binden, aber die haben eben nicht wie die Erde und Merkur die Sonneneinstrahlung funktionieren von daher anders. Aber das ist eigentlich von ihrer Zusammensetzung vergleichbar. Deswegen sind auch diese Missionen dahin so interessant.
So ist es. Also die zwei großen Missionen, die man in den letzten 15 Jahren ins äußere Sonnensystem gestartet hatte, also zunächst Galileo zum Jupitersystem und dann jetzt eben vor allem Cassini ins Saturnsystem. Deren Aufgabe ist es eben praktisch solche Prozesse, wie wir sie im inneren Sonnensystem in der Frühzeit hatten, dort im äußeren Sonnensystem zu studieren. Und eben zu sehen, auch was ist dort anders. Was kann man von so einer Welt, die sehr viel weiter draußen ist und sehr viel kälter ist, was kann man da draus lernen? Also da gab es sehr viele interessante Dinge, die sich vor allem durch Cassini in den letzten Jahren ergeben haben. Wir haben Eismonde am Saturn, die sprühen Wasserfontänen ins All, so ähnlich wie unser Vulkanismus im inneren Sonnensystem, bloß nicht mit Magma und Lava, sondern eben, dass dort wie Geysire Wasser ins All gesprüht wird durch Wärme, die sich entwickelt durch Reibungskräfte im Inneren von solchen Körpern. Wir sehen beim größten Mond, der Saturn, der heißt Titan, der hat einen Durchmesser von 5.000 Kilometern, eigentlich schon ein kleiner Planet, oder ein veritabler Planet, wenn man so möchte, sehen wir eine ganz dichte Atmosphäre, die in gewissen Grenzen der Atmosphäre der Erde gleicht, aber weil eben die Temperaturen so niedrig sind, minus 170 Grad Celsius, die Prozesse in dieser Atmosphäre sehr viel langsamer ablaufen als in der Erdatmosphäre. Und vermuten eben, dass man da einiges davon lernen kann, wie die Prozesse in der frühen Atmosphäre der Erde waren, als sich die Erdatmosphäre von einer Kohlendioxidatmosphäre langsam durch die Entwicklung des Lebens zu einer Stickstoff-Sauerstoffatmosphäre verändert hat, ohne dass man jetzt annimmt, wirklich Leben auf diesem Titanmond zu entdecken. Aber doch zumindest studieren kann in einer Umgebung, wo es sehr viele organische Moleküle hat, also Kohlenstoff-Wasserstoffverbindungen, zu studieren, welche chemischen Prozesse vielleicht günstig waren für die Entwicklung von frühem Leben auf der Erde und welche vielleicht ausscheiden würden.
Bevor wir zu dem Aspekt Leben kommen, wollte ich noch mal so ein bisschen die Entstehung der Planeten selber noch mal ein bisschen besprechen. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwiefern es Sinn macht, die Gasplaneten und die Steinsplaneten auseinanderzuhalten. Oder kann man die dann auch gemeinsam betrachten? Die haben eigentlich eine ganz andere Genese durchgemacht. Oder ist das dann doch letztlich vergleichbar?
Ja, das ist richtig. Eigentlich direkter Vergleich. Also es haben sich doch nicht sehr viele ähnliche Prozesse einfach abgespielt. Also man würde besser die Planeten des Inneren System untereinander zu vergleichen beginnen. Und dort eben von der Erde ausgehend zunächst sich überlegen, warum haben sich schon allein die Nachbarplaneten unterschiedlich entwickelt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die vier inneren Planeten plus der Mond, der Erde, der ja so gewissermaßen auch planetare Eigenschaften hat, als eine Gruppe sagen, die sind alle gleich und genauso kann man das auch nicht sagen für die vier Planeten im äußeren Sonnensystem. Sondern interessant ist eigentlich schon allein der Aspekt, warum sich wirklich mit zunehmender Entfernung von der Sonne jedes Mal ein individueller anderer Planetenkörper gebildet hat und was das wiederum bedeutet für die Entwicklung der Erde.
Aber dann bleiben wir doch vielleicht mal kurz noch bei den Gasplaneten, weil die eben der Sonne so ähnlich sind. Was muss man sich vorstellen Gasplanet? Also ist das jetzt wirklich alles nur Gas? Oder kann man schon auch davon ausgehen, dass es da einen festen Anteil in gewisser Form auch noch irgendwo gibt? Haben die irgendwo noch so einen Kern, den wir auch als solchen bezeichnen wollen würden?
Also wir waren noch nie da drin. Das geht nicht, die Drücke sind zu hoch. Man hat es versucht, also zumindest ein Stück weit reinzukommen. Mit dieser Galileo-Raumsonde reiste eine Kapsel mit, die am Fallschirm dann in die Atmosphäre des Jupiter eingetaucht ist. Und dort sank sie immer tiefer, bis der Druck so hoch wurde, dass die Sonde dann vom Atmosphärendruck zerquetscht wurde. Bis dahin hatte sie also Daten zum Mutterschiff übertragen, hat aufgezeichnet, wie viel Blitze sie dort sieht von Gewittern, wie viel Luftfeuchtigkeit es dort hat, welche Temperaturen, welche Windstärken es dort hat. Aber das war wirklich nur Kratzen an der Oberfläche oder ein kleines Eintauchen in die Atmosphäre. Alles andere wird modelliert, also praktisch mit den Daten, die man hat aufgrund von astronomischen Aufzeichnungen und von Messungen, die man hat, indem die Raumschiffe um diesen Planeten rumfliegen, wie Galileo oder Voyager damals in den 70er-Jahren. Und weiß anhand von Modellen, die man Druck- und Temperaturdiagrammen entnimmt, dass mit zunehmender Tiefe das ganz interessant wird in so einem Planeten wie Jupiter oder wie Saturn. Das heißt, diese normale Gasschicht gerät dann immer mehr unter Druck, durch den eigenen Druck. Dadurch lösen sich dann die Elektronen von den Atomkern, sodass man ab einer gewissen Tiefe eine Art Elektronengas hat und mit noch größerer Tiefe dieses Gas dann metallische Eigenschaften annimmt, also hochgradig leitend ist. Deswegen z.B. der Jupiter ein Magnetfeld entwickelt, das sehr, sehr stark ist. Und mit noch größerer Tiefe wird das dann eine Art Plasmaschicht, die Zustände hat, die wir auf der Erde überhaupt nicht simulieren können. Wahrscheinlich hat sogar der Jupiter in seinem Innersten dann auch einen Gesteinskern, wo also die schweren Elemente konzentriert sind, der vielleicht sogar so groß ist wie die ganze Erde, allerdings unter unglaublich hohem Druck steht.
Aber das lässt sich sozusagen nur vermuten bisher?
Das lässt sich vermuten und eben anhand der Modelle, der Druck- und Temperaturmodelle, die man für bestimmte Elemente in Elementzusammensetzungen hat, dann eben...
Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, dass diese Gasplaneten jetzt nicht vollständig nur Gas sind, aber eben vor allem und im Wesentlichen und im Verhältnis dazu sehr viel weniger Gestein enthalten, aber dadurch, dass das Ganze sehr viel größer ist als jetzt die Erde, kann es eben sein, dass da tatsächlich eine komplette Erde drin ist. Und wenn da auch immer wieder Asteroiden reinfliegen, wird das ja im Prinzip auch permanent genert.
Genau, das ist richtig, ja. Aber das spielt wahrscheinlich von einer Masse keine Rolle. Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Und das heißt auch, Jupiter, Saturn, Neptun, Uranus sind auch alle sehr unterschiedlich?
Sie sind vielleicht weniger unterschiedlich als die Planeten im inneren Sonnensystem. Über Uranus und Neptun weiß man auch noch nicht wirklich sehr viel, weil es nur praktisch einen einzigen Vorbeiflug gab, der umfangreiche Experimente gemacht hat. Das war damals diese Grand Tour von Voyager 2, wo also die Planeten in so einer geschickten Konstellation waren, dass eben mit einem Schuss praktisch Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus und Neptun besucht werden konnten und zum ersten Mal von all diesen Himmelskörpern Aufnahmen aus der Nähe gemacht werden konnten und eben auch Experimente zum Strahlungsumfeld, zum Magnetfeld und all diese Dinge.
Basisdaten. Würde es denn da nochmal eine Mission geben?
Also zunächst ist mal eine Mission unterwegs zum neunten Planeten des Sonnensystems, der ja kein neunter Planet mehr ist. Aber als man die Mission geplant hat, war es natürlich noch der neunte zu Pluto. Das ist die Sonde New Horizons von der NASA, die 2015 am Pluto ankommen wird. Dann wird man also auch von diesem Planeten, in Anführungszeichen Zwergplanet ist es ja jetzt...
2005, 2015.
2015... .wird man zum ersten Mal Aufnahmen haben. Der wird dann vorbeifliegen und dann wird man sich noch ein zweites Ziel suchen, irgendwo ganz weit draußen, das eben vielleicht auch noch angesteuert werden kann. Das ist noch nicht klar, welcher Kleinplanet oder Zwergplanet es sein wird. Und zum Neptune, könnte ich mir vorstellen, wäre auch ein sehr interessantes Ziel, das man nochmal ansteuern sollte, vor allem wegen seines größten Mondes, dem Triton, der total spannend ist und wo es also ganz fantastische Aufnahmen gibt von der Voyager-2-Sonde und wo man eben auch die Vermutung hat, dass es dort Prozesse auf der Oberfläche gibt, die zumindest ansatzweise eine gewisse Dynamik zeigen. Das heißt, dort entweder hat es im Inneren dieses Triton-Mondes eine Wärmequelle, die dafür sorgt, dass auf der Oberfläche vulkanismusartige Vorgänge sich abspielen oder es sind eben Sublimationsprozesse, wo diese winzige Wärme, die noch von der Sonne ankommt, dafür sorgt, dass Eis und Gas in eine Wechselwirkung treten und so Veränderungen auf der Oberfläche und Atmosphäre sich abspielen. Das wäre also ziemlich spannend. Bei diesen ganzen Projekten muss man natürlich nur immer sich vor Augen führen, ein menschliches Leben ist endlich und Raumschiffe sind langsam. Das soll man jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht glauben, dass Raumschiffe langsam sind, wenn sie mit Raketen starten. Aber tatsächlich dauert das viele Jahre, bis eine Sonde an so einem Ziel ankommt, weil man heutzutage nicht mehr auf direktem Weg das ansteuern kann, weil die Triebwerke nicht stark genug sind, sondern dass man die Schwerkraft von Körpern im inneren Sonnensystem anzapft und dadurch Schwung aufnimmt und dadurch viele Jahre verliert.
Aber eine Menge Treibstoff spart.
Eine Menge Treibstoff spart, ja.
Das war ja hier auch schon das Thema in der Sendung zur Missionsplanung.
Bei Rosetta, ganz genau.
Vor allem an dem Beispiel Rosetta entlang gehangelt haben, so wie sich Rosetta am Sonnensystem entlanghangelt, kann man ja fast sagen. Das ist wie so ein Affe, der sich von Baum zu Baum schwingt. Schwingen sich diese Satelliten von Planet zu Planet. Du hast es angesprochen, Zwergplaneten, ein vergleichsweise neuer Begriff, der ja unter großen Streit oder Diskussion zumindest in der astronomischen Gemeinschaft neu eingeführt wurde. Und damit wurde Pluto, der Planetenstatus, zum Zwergplaneten gemacht. Und es gibt jetzt diese neue Definition der Bahnfreiräumung, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Was steckt da genau dahinter? Etwas Ähnliches, über das wir vorhin schon mal gesprochen haben, dass man sagen kann, wenn sich die Planeten gebildet haben, haben sie den planetaren Müll praktisch aus dem Weg geräumt und sich einverleibt in den planetaren Körper. Im äußeren Sonnensystem ist es ein bisschen anders, weil die Entfernung zwischen die Räume, wo nichts ist und dort, wo ab und zu mal was vorbeikommt, natürlich sehr viel größer sind. Wenn man streng argumentieren würde, dann könnte man sagen, selbst der Neptun hat seine Bahn nicht freigeräumt, weil er eine Resonanz hat mit Pluto. Pluto kreuzt die Neptunbahn. In einem Verhältnis von drei zu zwei umrunden diese beiden Körper die Sonne. Dadurch kommt es immer wieder zu Bahnkreuzungen, dass Pluto mal innerhalb der Neptunbahn ist und dann mal wieder außerhalb. Das heißt, die Neptunbahn ist nicht wirklich freigeräumt, weil dort Pluto ab und zu noch...
Das heißt, der Neptun müsste sich den Pluto einverleiben.
Das wird aber so schnell nicht geschehen, weil immer dann, wenn Pluto die Neptunbahn kreuzt, ist der Neptun ganz woanders. Das passiert nicht. Aber es ist ganz streng.
Aber irgendwann wird es doch mal passieren, oder nicht?
Das haben wir jetzt nicht modelliert, aber vielleicht könnte das so sein. Das bin ich überfragt. Aber das ist noch lange hin sozusagen. Nicht in unserem Leben.
Aber was würde denn passieren, wenn Pluto jetzt tatsächlich sehr nahe kommen würde? Ich meine, wenn er auftrifft direkt, was jetzt noch mal sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dann kann man gar nicht sagen, was da passiert.
Es gibt durchaus vergleichbare Fälle vermutlich im Sonnensystem, dass solche Dinge passieren, dass zwei relativ große Körper miteinander kollidiert sind. Das erkennt man daran, dass z.B. der Uranus auf seiner Bahn mehr rollt als das, dass er praktisch aufrecht kreiselt. Das heißt, er hat seinen Nordpol praktisch zur Sonne ausgerichtet und die andere Pol-Achse in die Ferne des Weltalls. er ist in eine Schieflage geraten. Und das ist vermutlich dadurch geschehen, dass eben auch ein größerer Körper mit ihm kollidiert ist. Wir wissen auch, dass in der Frühzeit des Sonnensystems die Erde von einem großen Planetenkörper getroffen wurde. Daraus entstand dann der Mond beispielsweise. Was ganz ähnliches hat man vor kurzem von dem Mars angenommen, dass der auch mal getroffen wurde. Also das scheint kein zu seltener Prozess zu sein. Und der Neptun würde die Kollision mit dem Pluto wahrscheinlich auch überleben.
Und vielleicht sich da wieder aufrichten.
Vielleicht doch wieder aufrichten, ja.
Ist denn diese Eigenrotation überhaupt ein Merkmal aller Planeten?
Da müsste man jetzt einen Bahnmechaniker fragen. Ich glaube, dass es praktisch zwingend ist, dass Planeten Eigenrotation haben, weil sie einfach den Drehimpuls mitnehmen aus der Scheibe und dadurch drehen müssen.
Aber alles dreht sich?
Alles dreht sich.
Jupiter dreht sich, Erde dreht sich. Und diese Drehung ist dann eigentlich normalerweise quasi wirklich die Achse senkrecht zur Sonne. Zu dieser 90 Grad zur Scheibe.
Das ist der Idealfall. Zunächst mal, dass sie alle im gleichen Dreh sind, rotieren wie die Sonne auch, die ja auch eine eigene Rotation hat. Nur bei der Venus ist das andersrum. Die Venus dreht auch seltsamerweise andersrum. Und scheint also diesen Impuls von einer Kollision bekommen zu haben. Zumindest vermutet man das. Wissen tut man es nicht mit Gewissheit. Und idealerweise sind auch alle Planeten in einer Ebene. Das nennt man die Ekliptik, also die Ebene der Erde um die Sonne. Die Sonne definiert die Ekliptik. Und alle anderen sieben Planeten sind fast in derselben Ebene. Nur eben wiederum der Pluto auch nicht. Und das hat eben auch dazu geführt, dass er ausgesondert wurde, weil er mit einem Winkel von 17 Grad zur Ekliptik eben geneigt ist.
Aber er ist schon rund.
Er ist kugelrund.
Das heißt, er ist groß genug, um diese Idealform sozusagen anzunehmen. Also wie viel Masse braucht man denn so als Planet, bis man wirklich rund ist?
In Masse kann ich es jetzt nicht ausdrücken, aber wir wissen eben beispielsweise von den Monden am Jupiter und am Saturn, dass so eine Minimalgröße von 300 bis 400 Kilometer Durchmesser etwa gegeben sein muss, damit ein Körper isostatisches Gleichgewicht erreicht und dann praktisch eine Kugelform annimmt.
Aber so richtig eine Kugel ist ja auch die Erde nicht. Also wenn man es jetzt mal ganz geometrisch betrachtet, ist das Ding ja nicht wirklich rund.
Eigentlich ist keiner dieser Körper eine perfekte Billardkugel, sondern alle sind irgendwie ein bisschen abgeplattet oder haben Dellen oder sind ausgebeult in eine Richtung. Bei den Gasplaneten ist es sogar noch relativ extrem der Fall, weil die relativ schnell rotieren und Gas eben flüchtige Elemente sind. Und dadurch eben, dass dieser Effekt der Rotation am Äquator natürlich sehr viel größer ist als am Pol, wo direkt um die Polachse rotiert die Masse. Und deswegen diese Körper in der Äquator-Ebene einen größeren Durchmesser haben als in Nord-Süd-Richtung von Pol zu Pol. Und deswegen sind die...
Also kürbisartig.
Kürbisartig, wenn man so möchte. Dazu kommt noch bei den Körpern mit festen Bestandteilen, wie jetzt der Mond oder die Masse und die Erde, dass eben die Massen ungleich verteilt sein können zusätzlich noch und es sich dadurch eben auch zu Verformungen kommen kann. Weil die Gravitation dann unterschiedlich ist. Auf dem Mond ist es ziemlich extrem.
Also, Wasserverteilung, ist das jetzt etwas, was man noch gar nicht genau weiß? Oder beziehen wir uns jetzt hier auf Erde, Wasserverteilung auf den Planeten?
Na, beim Mond ist es eben so, dass der Mond ungleiche Verteilung von leichten und schweren Elementen hat. Also, eisenreiche Lawen, also Magman-Körper oder so was, sorgen dann eben auch dafür, dass der Körper eine unterschiedliche Dimension hat, vor allem auch unterschiedliche Gravitation. Das wiegt eigentlich noch viel schwerer. Und beim Mond ist man sich zum Beispiel nicht so ganz sicher, warum seine Rückseite etwas mächtiger ist als seine Vorderseite. Das heißt, die Kruste auf der Rückseite ist sehr viel dicker als die Kruste auf der Vorderseite. Es kann sein, dass es mit der Entstehungsgeschichte zusammenhängt. Es kann andere Ursachen haben, durch Gezeitenkräfte, beispielsweise Fliehkräfte, die dann auf der Rückseite eben stärker wurden als auf der Mondvorderseite. Also keiner dieser Körper ist eine perfekte Billardkugel.
Was hat es denn für eine Ursache? Ich meine, man sieht ja von dem Mond immer nur eine Seite. Trotzdem dreht er sich ja um die Erde. Das heißt, er hat an sich genau genommen auch eine Eigenrotation, die aber genau so ist, dass man ihn immer nur von einer Seite sieht. Das heißt, einmal rum um die Erde heißt auch, er dreht sich auch um sich selbst einmal rum.
Genau. Ist das ein Wunder oder ist das normal? Nein, das ist ein Normalfall, den wir also auch bei vielen Monden im äußeren Sonnensystem sehen. Das nennt man eine gebundene Rotation. Die zeigen also ihren Planeten immer das gleiche Gesicht. So etwas Ähnliches vermutet man auch von dem Merkur, dass der durch die unglaublich starke Anziehungskraft der Sonne zumindest nicht weit davon entfernt ist, dass er sich auch in so einer Situation einpendelt. Bei Merkurs ist die Situation ganz kompliziert. Er dreht sich dreimal um sich selber, während er zweimal um die Sonne kreist, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe. Dadurch stehen die Tages- und Jahreslängen in einem völlig verrückten Verhältnis zueinander. Das hat möglicherweise eine Ursache darin, dass dieser Körper sich noch nicht ganz perfekt auf diese gebundene Rotation von der Sonne hat zwingen lassen. Bei allen anderen Planeten ist es so, dass die schön um sich selber drehen und diese Rotation beibehalten. Deswegen zeigt die Sonne nicht immer die gleiche Säde. Das hat für uns hier keine Vorteile. Sondern Aufgang, Sondern Untergang, kalt und warm.
Stimmt. Konzentrieren wir uns doch vielleicht mal mehr auf die Erde-ähnlichen Planeten, bzw. auch der Erde selbst. Das sind jetzt diejenigen, die die ganzen schweren Bestandteile des Alls auch oder vor allem mitbekommen haben. Aber die Gase in dem Sinne sind ja auch Teil des Ganzen. Was ist jetzt sozusagen geschehen, als die sich zusammengeklumpt haben aus diesem Urgasnebel dieser Scheibe, die sich um die Sonne herumgemacht hat? Also klar, die haben sich irgendwie gefunden. Das hatten wir ja schon. Die Gravitation hat dazu zusammengeführt, dass sie sich zusammenballen. Dadurch, dass jetzt so viele schwere Anteile sind, waren sie quasi kein Kandidat dafür, selber sonnenartig zu werden. Und dann?
Ja, das ist eine ziemlich interessante Geschichte. Was geschah dann? Und wirklich wissen, mit großer Gewissheit, sag ich mal wissen, tut man es erst, seit man den Mond in den 60er und 70er Jahren ziemlich intensiv untersucht hat durch das Apollo-Projekt. Kamen sehr viele Proben zur Erde, knapp 400 Kilogramm, die man sehr genau analysiert hat. Die meisten Proben waren älter als dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahre, manche über vier Milliarden Jahre, also sehr jung, von der ursprünglichen Kruste, der allerersten Kruste, die sich auf dem Mond gebildet hat. Und man hatte vorher schon praktisch immer eine Diskussion geführt, haben sich die Planeten heiß oder kalt gebildet. Waren das heiße Kugeln oder waren das kalte Kugeln? Und erst durch die Untersuchung des Mondes ist man eigentlich darauf gekommen, dass sich die Planeten heiß gebildet haben. Das heißt, diese Kugeln haben sich zusammengeballt. Und durch diesen Prozess der Zusammenballung, das nennt man Aggression, dass ich so wenig der Faust in die Hand schlage und merke, das wird ein bisschen warm auf der Haut, einfach durch Reibung, durch diesen Aufschlag, da wird Energie übertragen, haben sich diese Protoplaneten aufgeheizt. Dazu kam noch, dass in dieser Masse, ursprünglichen Masse aller Planeten sehr viele radioaktive Elemente ganz natürlich dabei waren, entsprechend der Häufigkeit, wie sie eben im All oder in dieser Umgebung, dieser Sonne vorkamen. Diese radioaktive Energie hat zusätzlich dazu beigetragen, dass dieser Planet aufgeheizt wird. Und man hat dann eben herausbekommen, dass sich vermutlich die Aufheizung so stark abgespielt hat, dass der Planet einen Magma-Ozean an seiner Oberfläche hatte, der im Falle des Mondes ein paar 100 Kilometer tief war und im Falle der Erde wahrscheinlich ein bis 2000 Kilometer tief war. Also ein Ozean aus glühendem Gestein. Und dann passierte eben auch noch...
Aber das muss ja dann nach diesem Einschlag gewesen sein, den wir eben vermutet haben auf der Erde.
Bei Mond war das nach diesem Einschlag. Das ist eine separate Geschichte. Gehen wir mal einfach nur von der Erde oder von der Venus und von Mars und von Merkur aus. Dann hat sich eben diese Kruste oder dieser Planet so aufgeheizt, dass er glühend war und seine Ohrfläche glühend heiß und dann in seine Bestandteile entsprechend ihrer Dichte, entsprechend ihrer Schwere aufgetrennt hat. Das heißt, wie in jedem Suppentopf, den man auf den Herd stellt, sinken die Fleischbröckchen, die schweren Bröckchen runter und die leichten Bestandteile, der Wirsing und der Lauch, die schwimmen oben. So bildete sich in diesen Körpern ein Kern aus den schwersten Elementen, meistens Eisen und Nickel, mit Anteilen von Schwäfel heraus. Darüber bildete sich ein Mantel aus den nicht ganz so schweren Bestandteilen und gegen die Kälte des Alts bildete sich dann die erste Kruste, als der Planet langsam abkühlte, mit den leichtesten Elementen, die oben aufschwammen.
Und die Abkühlung wurde im Prinzip dadurch eingeleitet, dass nicht mehr viel weitere Materie einzusammeln war. Also diese Erhitzung war sozusagen durch das fortlaufende, weitere Aufschlagen und Zusammenführen mit sonstiger Materie in der Umlaufbahn.
Das trifft es wahrscheinlich ziemlich genau. Und man vermutet eigentlich, dass so eine Planetenbildung in etwa zehn Millionen Jahren abgeschlossen war, was ein relativ kurzer Zeitraum ist, wenn man sich vor Augen hält, dass das ganze Sonnensystem 4,5 Milliarden Jahre alt ist. Und auch dieser Prozess der Differenziation, also das Schwere sinkt zum Kern und bildet ein Kern aus. Und die leichteren Bestandteile treiben nach oben, ging relativ zügig vonstatten. Und was dann im Anschluss passiert, nachdem die erste Kruste sich gebildet hatte, das ist dann jetzt wieder eine Frage, wie es an jedem einzelnen Planeten wirklich stattgefunden hat. Weil die Planeten sind unterschiedlich groß. Sie befinden sich in unterschiedlich großer Entfernung zum Zentralgestirn, empfangen also unterschiedlich viel Energie. Sodass dann ab dem Zeitpunkt eben dann auch jeder Körper seine individuelle Geschichte hat, gewissermaßen.
Und auch wegen dieser unterschiedlichen spezifischen Schwere. Das heißt, im Merkur ist noch sehr viel mehr Eisen untergekommen als in der Erde? Oder gibt es noch mal ganz andere?
Ja, beim Merkur scheint ein Sonderfall vorzuliegen, denn der Merkur hat einen auffallend großen Eisenkern gegenüber dem Mantel, der diesen Kern umgibt. Und das hat schon viele Leute immer gewundert, warum das so ist. Und eine der Vermutungen ist eben, dass auch der Merkur von einem großen Körper irgendwann mal getroffen wurde und dadurch sehr viel Mantelmaterial abgesprengt wurde wieder. Sodass deswegen der Kern jetzt relativ groß ist im Verhältnis zu seinem Mantel und der kleinen Kruste. Aber interessant ist beispielsweise der Vergleich von Venus und Erde. Beides fast gleichgroße Körper haben sich aber ganz unterschiedlich entwickelt, zumindest so wie wir es heute eben sehen. Und da spielt möglicherweise eine Rolle, dass die Venus, weil sie etwas näher an der Sonne ist, sehr viel weniger flüchtige Bestandteile, sprich Wasser oder so etwas, oder ähnliche Gase eben hat behalten können als jetzt die Erde. Das heißt, diese Gase wurden der Venus ausgetrieben. Vielleicht hat sie auch von vornherein weniger Gase gehabt, sodass der Prozess der Plattentechtonik, der ja für die Erde ganz bezeichnend ist, weil die Kontinente sich dauernd verschieben und dadurch der Erdmandel gewissermaßen an den Nahtstellen der Kontinente wie Ventile hat in Formen von Vulkanen, wo die Hitze aus dem Inneren, die immer noch erzeugt wird, abgeleitet werden kann und das auf der Venus eben nicht der Fall ist. Auf der Venus haben wir einen Einplattenplanet, unter dessen Größte sich immer wieder wohl Hitze angestaut hat, bis es dann zu einer möglicherweise globalen Katastrophe kam. Diese Hitze sich bahnbrach und an Tausenden von Vulkanen gleichzeitig dann ausgebrochen ist. Ob es gleichzeitig war, sei mal dahingestellt, aber in einer relativ kurzen Zeitspanne.
Das heißt, es ist sozusagen auch wieder so ein kleines Wunder, dass bei der Erde so verteilt ist, dass es so mehr oder weniger permanent die ganze Zeit passiert.
Genau. Das Wasser, das bei uns nicht nur in den Ozeanen ist, sondern eben auch in den Gesteinen, in den Kristallgittern der Gesteine ist. Wenn diese Gesteine dann tiefer in den Erdmantel reingezogen werden, dann wird dieses Wasser zum Teil diesen Gesteinen ausgetrieben und wirkt dann eben bei der Platten-Tektonik als Schmiermittel, sodass dieser Prozess relativ leicht und reibungslos vonstattengeht. Das scheint also ein ganz entscheidender Faktor zu sein, was die Erde von der Venus unterscheidet.
Wie verhält sich denn das Wasser in diesem ganzen Gravitationsspiel? Ich meine, in der ursprünglichen Verteilung wäre jetzt hier, wie schwere Materie mitbekommt. Klar, Eisen haben wir schon gehört, aber das Wasser, was ja nun auch eine wichtige Rolle spielt, wie dürfte sich das denn auf diese Planeten verteilt haben?
Im Grunde genommen zunächst mal so, dass es, je weiter man wegkommt von der Sonne, Wasser stabiler wird. Wir benutzen Wasser als Begriff für alle drei Phasenzustände. Wasserdampf, Wasser als fließendes Wasser und Wasser als Eis. Das ist dann natürlich eine Frage, wie weit weg bin ich von der Sonne, welche Temperaturen das Wasser ausgesetzt ist. Da scheint es eben so zu sein, dass gerade die Erde in einer relativ günstigen Entfernung ist, wo Wasser in allen drei Phasenzuständen zurzeit wenigstens stabil ist. Das war sicherlich vor einigen Milliarden Jahren auch der Fall. Das unterscheidet die Erde zum Beispiel schon mal von der Venus und von Mars. Auf der Venus haben wir so hohe Temperaturen, durch die dichte Kohlendioxidatmosphäre, also der Treibhauseffekt, wurde sogar auf der Venus entdeckt, der uns heute auf der Erde auch zu schaffen macht, über den wir diskutieren. Der ist auf der Venus so intensiv, dass wir permanent Tag und Nacht und der Venus-Oberfläche zwischen 460 und 470 Grad Celsius haben. D.h., dort ist Wasser als flüssige Phase nicht stabil. Das bisschen Wasser, das die Venus noch hat, befindet sich in ganz hohen Atmosphärenschichten. Es ist also kein Vergleich zu der Menge an Wasser, das die Erde an sich bindet. Es könnten also keine Ozeane entstehen. Deswegen ist die Venus als Kandidat für einen Planeten, auf dem Leben stattfinden könnte, relativ ungeeignet.
Und der Merkur ist einfach nur heiß?
Es kommt drauf an, wo sie sich befinden. Wenn du auf der Merkur-Vorderseite bist, dann ist es teuflisch heiß. Aber sobald der Planet in die Nacht reinrotiert, ist es von einem auf den anderen Moment furchtbar kalt. Es ist der Planet mit den höchsten Temperaturunterschieden. Das unterscheidet ihn dann wiederum von der Venus, weil die Venus die Temperatur praktisch in die Nacht mit rein nimmt. Und dadurch überall gleich heiß ist. Und auf dem Merkur ist es eben ohne Atmosphäre extrem. Da sind die Temperaturunterschiede ganz extrem. Der Merkur hat...
Wie man das hier aus der Wüste nur kennt, in kleinen Maßstaben.
Genau. Sobald die Sonne untergeht, wird es furchtbar kalt. Der Merkur hat etwas, was man eigentlich nicht als Atmosphäre bezeichnet. Wir bezeichnen so etwas als Exosphäre. Das heißt, dort schwirren ein paar vereinzelte Natrium-Ionen, Natrium-Atome herum, die man aber nicht als Atmosphäre bezeichnen kann. Was auf dem Merkur ganz fast witzig, ironisch ist, ist, dass der Planet fast senkrecht auf seiner Bahn um die Sonne steht. Das heißt, die Rotationsachse steht wirklich senkrecht. Das heißt eben auch, man kann sich das vor Augen halten, wenn man einen Fußball nimmt und lässt auf den Fußball eine Nachttischlampe scheinen. Dann sieht man, dass das Nachttischlampenlicht den Nordpol und den Südpol des Fußballs eben nur streift. Wenn ich jetzt im Nordpol ein Loch, eine Grube reinmache, also einen Einschlagsgrader habe, dann streift das Licht über diesen Grader hinweg. So ist es auf dem Merkur eben auch. Das Sonnenlicht streift über die tiefen Grader am Nordpol und Südpol des Merkur und übrigens auch vom Erdmond hinweg. Und dadurch, dass keine Atmosphäre da ist, ist es dort, wo Schatten ist auf dem Merkur, eisekalt. Unter minus 200 Grad Celsius. Jetzt hat man mit Radarbeobachtungen von Arecibo rausgefunden, dass es dort Reflektionen hat in diesen Grader, die darauf hindeuten, dass dort möglicherweise Eis liegt, dass dort seit Millionen von Jahren vor dem Verdampfen geschützt ist. Und in diesen, wir nennen das Kältefallen, tatsächlich noch das eine oder andere Eisfeld vorhanden sein kann, wo Eis von Kometen möglicherweise reingebracht wurde. Das hat man ja auf dem Mond jetzt auch nachgewiesen, dieses Wasser. Und das macht die Sache mit dem Mond natürlich als zukünftige Forschungsstation auch wieder ganz spannend, dass man vielleicht dieses Wasser mal nutzen könnte.
Ja, schauen wir doch mal auf die Erde. Ich meine, die Erde unterscheidet sich, wissen wir ja, doch ganz erheblich von seinen Nachbarn, allein schon, weil es uns da gibt. Und hier kommt ja auch dieser Aspekt Leben mit herein, das, was man immer ganz gerne mal auch von woanders gerne sehen wollen würde. Aber was, meine ich, wir hatten ja die Erde, hat sich gebildet, war heiß, hat jetzt diese Besonderheit, dass dieser heiß-kalt-Wechsel nicht so umschlagen, dass die ganze Oberfläche explodiert, sondern ist so ein Fort, während das Durchrühren eigentlich so der Oberfläche. Ist ein bisschen hart, ein bisschen weich. Von beiden ist irgendwie was dabei. Und ganz offensichtlich haben wir hier eine Atmosphäre, die uns das Überleben erlaubt. Aber die war ja am Anfang nicht da. Also die muss ich ja auch erst mal irgendwie gebildet haben. Ich meine, die schweren Dinge sind innen, die leichten Teile sind ohnehin schon an der Oberfläche. Aber was hat sich denn da angesammelt? Was ist so?
In der Frühzeit dieser Planeten, das trifft für die Venus genauso zu wie für den Mars, also beide Nachbarplaneten, waren all diese Körper vulkanisch sehr viel aktiver, weil einfach viel Wärme im Inneren noch da war. Und deswegen wurde viel von den Gasen, die sich bei der Zusammenballung dieser Planeten mit angesammelt haben, einfach gewissermaßen ausgetrieben aus den Gesteinen und durch den Vulkanismus rausgeblasen. Und dann hängt es davon ab, wie viel Masse hat so ein Planet und welche Atmosphäre kann er an sich binden. Das heißt, die Erde und die Venus sind relativ große Planeten und haben dadurch genügend Masse, eine relativ dichte Atmosphäre an sich zu binden, sodass diese flüchtigen Elemente nicht gleich wieder Fluchtgeschwindigkeit erreichen und durch Kollisionen oder durch Interaktion mit dem Sonnenwind oder mit anderer kosmischer Strahlung aufgespalten werden und dann weg sind sie und dann sind sie ins All verloren. Dazu kommt noch, dass die Erde ein Magnetfeld hat. Dieses Magnetfeld leitet eben auch eine ganze Menge Sonnenwind und kosmischer Strahlung, energiereicher Strahlung um die Erde herum, was für das Leben dann auch sehr günstig ist. Und dadurch eben auch weniger gasförmige Moleküle aufgespalten werden und Fluchtgeschwindigkeiten erreichen.
Okay, Merkur und Venus haben kein Magnetfeld?
Der Merkur hat auch ein starkes Magnetfeld, aber er ist zu klein, um wiederum eine Atmosphäre an sich zu binden. Und der Sonnenwind ist dort extrem stark. Die Venus hat ein schwaches Magnetfeld, aber die Atmosphäre ist ja auch da. Also er kann auch eine große Atmosphäre an sich binden.
Aber warum ist das Magnetfeld schwach? Was macht das Magnetfeld? Also wodurch entsteht dieses Magnetfeld überhaupt?
Das Magnetfeld entsteht bei der Erde durch eine leitende Masse. Also flüssiges Eisen, das in Bewegung ist. Der Dynamoeffekt, den wir beim Fahrrad auch haben. Das heißt, der äußere Kern der Erde ist flüssig und der innere Kern der Erde ist fest. Beides ist metallisch leitend und dann kann das ein Magnetfeld erzeugen. Und das ist natürlich für die Erde von ganz entscheidendem Vorteil.
Das heißt, das flüssige Eisen rotiert um den harten, festen Kern.
Und dadurch werden elektrische Felder erzeugt.
Durch Induktion wird dann dieses Feld erzeugt.
Ganz genau.
Und das findet bei der Venus nicht statt, weil der Kern fehlt?
Der Kern ist auch da, aber es ist vermutlich kein so ausgeprägter flüssiger Teil.
Zumindest nicht genug, um wirklich ein starkes Magnetfeld zu machen, um wirklich denselben Schutzmantel zu haben, wie das die Erde hat.
Genau. Und bei Mars ist es auch so, dass eben nur ein kleiner Kern aus Metall, aus Eisen da ist und eben auch nur eigentlich kein Magnetfeld erzeugt, heute zumindest nicht mehr. Es kann sein, dass der Mars früher mal ein Magnetfeld hatte, der schwach ist.
Das Magnetfeld der Erde ist so stark, dass es eben den Sonnenwind von der Sonne, das war es ja sozusagen auch die Dimension des Sonnensystems, wenn wir es vorhin festgehalten haben, ja auch ausmacht. Dieses permanente Abstrahlen hat sozusagen Vor- und Nachteile. Und was ist genau der Sonnenwind? Also was trifft dort auf, was von dem Magnetfeld abgehalten wird?
Zunächst mal ist es für die Atmosphäre wichtig, dass der planetare Körper eine gewisse Größe hat, dass diese Atmosphäre überhaupt an den Planeten gebunden werden kann. Und wenn wir die Erde von außen betrachten, dann sehen wir, dass es wirklich nur eine hauchdünne Schicht ist, eine Pfirsichhaut gewissermaßen um die Erde. So wirklich mächtig ist diese Atmosphäre auch nicht. Weil wir alle schon mal auf dem Mount Everest waren, in 9 km Höhe die Luft ziemlich dünn schon ist. Und dann nimmt das ja exponentiell weiterhin ab. Und bei der Erde ist es eben der glückliche Umstand, dass dann noch das Magnetfeld dazukommt, eine dichte Atmosphäre vorhanden ist und dadurch natürlich das Leben geschützt ist auf der Erde. Und das macht einen ganz großen Unterschied zu unseren Nachbarplaneten aus.
Aber jetzt nur zum Verständnis. Was genau trägt der Sonnenwind an die Erde heran?
Das ist energiereiche Strahlung eben. Wir sehen, diese Strahlung kann in Wechselwirkung mit dem Magnetfeld treten, z.B. in den Polarlichtern im Nord- und Südpol. Das kann Zellleben zerstören oder zumindest schädigen. wenn wir uns außerhalb dieses Magnetfeldes als Lebewesen bewegen, hat das massive Auswirkungen auf das Leben. Und möglicherweise hat dieses Vorhandensein, das Magnetfeld, eine entscheidende Wirkung darauf gehabt, wie sich Leben auf der Erde hat entwickeln können.
diese ganze tektonische Eigenschaft der Erde, dass es fest und flüssig ist und dass es sich so viel bewegt, dass es so ein Wechselspiel ist zwischen fest und flüssig sowohl im Inneren für das Magnetfeld als auch im Äußeren für die Hülle, die sich permanent regeneriert immer wieder wandelt, die in der Lage ist, Einschläge auch wegzustecken. Dass das alles quasi die wichtige Voraussetzung war, dass sich Leben hat überhaupt erst mal entwickeln können, weil es genug Schutz vor der Außenwelt gibt.
Ob es wirklich so war, wissen wir nicht genau, aber es deutet vieles darauf hin, dass diese Faktoren, die du aufgezählt hast, alle eine gewisse Rolle gespielt haben. Die richtige Entfernung zur Sonne, sodass also Wasser, Wasserdampf und Eis stabil sind, dass eine Atmosphäre vorhanden ist, dass der Körper eine gewisse Größe hat, um diese Prozesse in seinem Inneren ablaufen zu lassen. Dass also zum einen das Magnetfeld am Kern erzeugt wird, andererseits eben durch Umwälzungen im Erdmantel, der Kern auch ein bisschen gekühlt wird, weil die heißen Massen steigen auf, es gibt oben ein bisschen Vulkanismus, dann sinkt kältere Kruste und Mantelmaterial wieder tiefer ab und kühlt dadurch den Kern im Inneren der Erde. Das sind alles einzelne Mosaiksteinchen, die darauf hindeuten, dass die günstig waren fürs Leben. Man kann natürlich das Pferd auch von der anderen Seite aufzäumen und sagen, das Leben hat sich an all diese Umstände so angepasst möglicherweise, wie es sie hier angetroffen hat. Das weiß man nicht. Wahrscheinlich erscheint uns, dass hier einfach günstige Bedingungen waren. Wir fassen das auch in einem Begriff zusammen, den nennt man die habitable Zone, also die bewohnbare Zone im Sonnensystem. Also gerade die richtige Entfernung zur Sonne und der Körper in der richtigen Größe, dass hier die Voraussetzungen deutlich günstiger waren, als auf unseren beiden Nachbarplaneten.
Was heißt es denn nun eigentlich Leben? Was ändert sich, was tritt ein, oder was muss eingetreten sein, dass man sagt, alles klar, jetzt haben wir hier Leben? Was macht das aus?
Das ist ein relativ junger Wissenschaftszweig, der sich damit natürlich sehr intensiv beschäftigt. Natürlich hat sich die Biologie schon immer damit beschäftigt, was eigentlich Leben ist, aber im kosmischen Maßstab wird diese Frage jetzt natürlich ganz anders betrachtet. Ich bin kein Exobiologe, das ist dieses neue Fachgebiet, Exobiologie. Für mich das wesentliche Kriterium ist wohl, dass etwas sich selber reproduziert. Durch Zellteilung oder durch andere Prozesse, die wir jetzt aber nicht kennen, ein Organismus entsteht, der sich selber immer wieder fortpflanzt und dadurch sich unterscheidet von toter Materie. Wenn ich einen Stein hinlege, dann kann ich Milliarden von Jahren drauf gucken, es werden keine zwei Steine draußen. Und wie das Leben genau auf der Erde entstanden ist, ist, so viel ich weiß, noch ein ganz großes Rätsel. Ob das jetzt der kosmische Blitz war, der in eine Ursuppe eingeschlagen hat, wo eben eine Konzentration von Kohlenstoff, Wasserstoffmoleküle vorhanden war, Aminosäuren, und sich dann auf einmal reproduktionsfähige Ketten von Molekülen gebildet haben, oder ob das ein länger dauernder evolutiver Prozess war, das können wir, glaube ich, noch nicht beantworten. Ist aber Gegenstand ganz intensiver Forschung gegenwärtig, weil man möchte ja wissen, ob man allein im Universum ist. Also die alte Frage ist da, wer stellt sich mehr denn je. Und ich denke mal, es ist vielleicht die spannendste Frage der Naturwissenschaften in diesem Jahrhundert, vielleicht auch noch länger, wer weiß. Aber es wird eben sehr, sehr viel intensiver jetzt an diesem Thema geforscht, herauszufinden, ob Leben auf der Erde Zufall ist, ob es zwingend ist, ob es einfach im Universum überall Leben geben kann, wo genau die gleichen Voraussetzungen da sind, wie bei uns hier auf der Erde. Also Entfernung zur Sonne, die richtige chemische Suppe, die richtige Größe und all diese Dinge. Oder ob es eben wirklich etwas Außergewöhnliches ist.
Wenn man jetzt versucht, irgendeinen Moment, nachdem weitgehend der Planet als solcher schon entstanden ist, und man schaut jetzt sozusagen auf einen Zeitpunkt, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt gab es noch kein Leben, in welchem Zustand befand sich dann die Erde? Also insbesondere, was jetzt so die Atmosphäre betraf. Vorhin klang das irgendwie schon an, dass es eine Umwandlung gab.
Ja, also die Ursubstanz der Erde oder der inneren Planeten hat eben durch das Ausgasen dafür gesorgt, dass diese inneren Planeten Venus, Erde und Mars Kohlendioxidatmosphären um sich herum gesammelt haben. Also das, was wir auf der Venus heute noch sehen, und auf dem Mars heute noch sehen, sind gewissermaßen Zustände wie bei uns auch vor vier Milliarden Jahren. Dann kam irgendwann auf der Erde eben das Leben dazu, hat sich relativ schnell entwickelt, zwischen dreieinhalb und vier Milliarden Jahren ist das Leben nach allem, was wir wissen, auf der Erde entstanden. Und hat dann relativ schnell begonnen, durch Stoffwechsel eben diese Atmosphäre zu verändern. Das heißt, die Organismen haben in Anführungszeichen geatmet, haben der Atmosphäre Kohlendioxid entzogen und haben das Kohlendioxid zugunsten von Sauerstoff abgereichert. Das heißt, die Atmosphäre hat sich nach und nach mit Sauerstoff angereichert. Das Kohlendioxid wanderte in Pflanzen und Mikroorganismen, später dann eben auch in kleine Tierchen, die Kalkskelette gebaut haben. Die Tierchen starben, sanken auf den Ozeanboden und wurden dort auf dem Förderband der Platten-Tektonik in den Erdmantel gezogen, wo sie dann zu Gebirgen aufgetürmt sind. Und wir heute auf der Zugspitze stehen in Bayern. Dann stehen wir auf Milliarden von Mikroorganismen, die aus Kalziumkarbonat bestehen. Und Kalziumkarbonat heißt eben, dass dort der Kohlenstoff unserer ursprünglichen Kohlendioxidatmosphäre jetzt als Gestein dort ist. Das heißt, unsere Atmosphäre hat sich eben durch Leben wirklich verändert, also im ganz großen Maßstab eben. Und das unterscheidet sie jetzt von unseren Nachbarplaneten.
Ist in diesen Gebirgen kein Eisen drin?
Natürlich auch. Alle Bodenschätze sind irgendwo dann auch da drin.
Aber eben auch extrem viel CO2. Das heißt, dass der Lebensprozess, unabhängig davon, wie er sich dann tatsächlich in Bewegung gesetzt hat, hat einfach dafür gesorgt, dass eigentlich im Wesentlichen das, was im Überfluss vorhanden war, nämlich CO2, umgesetzt wird in alles Mögliche. Dass man sich das sozusagen zunutze macht.
Das trifft zu, ja. Also man vermutet einfach, dass das Leben, sag ich mal, auf sechs Elementen beruht. Das ist Kohlenstoff, Wasserstoff in erster Linie, also die organische Chemie, wie wir es von der Schule her kennen. Dann eben Phosphor, Schwefel, Sauerstoff. Und jetzt kam eben in der vergangenen Woche die Entdeckung, dass gewisse Organismen eben auch statt Phosphor Arsen in ihr Erbmaterial als Element einbauen können. Ich bin viel zu wenig Spezialist auf diesem Gebiet, als dass ich da mehr dazu sagen kann, als das, was eben in den Medien kursiert. Das zeigt uns aber, dass unsere Vorstellung darüber, wie Leben aufgebaut sein muss, eben um eine ganz entscheidende Facette jetzt erweitert wurde, dass eben auch andere Elemente noch eine Rolle spielen können. Man wird ja oft gefragt, insbesondere, wenn ich jetzt, sag ich mal, Schulklassen habe und die Fragen, wie es denn mit der Suche nach Leben im Sonnensystem oder im Universum aussieht. Dann sag ich ja, nach allem, was wir wissen mit unserer Kohlenstoff-Wasserstoff-Chemie, sind wir auf der Suche. Es gibt den einen oder anderen Ort im Sonnensystem, wo wir das verdenkbar halten. Dann kommt sehr oft die Frage, Kohlenstoff kann vier Bindungen eingehen. Im Periodensystem direkt darüber ist das Silizium. Das kann auch vier Bindungen eingehen. Warum kann es nicht eine Lebenschemie auf der Basis von Silizium geben? Das ist eine total interessante Frage. Aber nach allem, was wir heute wissen, sind die Energiezustände, die dafür notwendig sind, mit Kohlenstoff vereinbar, dass sich eine vielseitige Chemie entwickelten. Bei Silizium geht das in der Form nicht. Wobei ganz viele unserer Gesteine auf dieser Silizium-Chemie beruhen. Das ist genau der Unterschied zwischen organischer Chemie und Silizium.
Sie können auch ihr eigenes Leben entwickeln.
Genau.
Vielleicht entwickelt sich da ja auch noch mal was draus.
Wenn man Computer als Organismus betrachtet, man kennt ja den häufigsten Dialog zum Computer. Was macht er denn jetzt? Man spricht ihm ein gewisses Leben zu.
Vielleicht, wenn man genug zuredet, dann tut sich da auch was von alleine. Diese Umwandlung der Atmosphäre, die war ja jetzt schon nicht unerheblich. Dadurch, dass die Organismen angefangen haben, das im Übermaß vorhandene CO2 umzuwandeln in alles Mögliche, hat sich sozusagen der gesamte Zustand der Atmosphäre geändert. Und es hat sich dadurch nicht nur die Atmosphäre geändert, sondern sie verhielt sich vermutlich anders gegenüber der Außenwelt. Das muss ja auch einen Einfluss daraus gehabt haben. Oder ist das eigentlich egal, woraus diese Atmosphäre besteht? In Bezug auf Strahlung, Abschirmung.
Das spielt keine so große Rolle. Das spielt keine so große Rolle.
Aber es war wichtig für die Temperatur.
Es spielt eine große Rolle für die Temperatur. Wenn wir nämlich keinen Kohlendioxid in der Atmosphäre hätten, dann wäre die Erde aufgrund der Strahlung, die sie in dieser Entfernung zur Sonne in 150 Millionen Kilometern empfängt, viel, viel kälter. Das heißt, wir hätten dann vermutlich Temperaturen zwischen minus 20 und minus 30 Grad permanent. Statt der Plus-Temperaturen, die wir im Durchschnitt ebenso auf der Erde haben. Von plus 8 Grad im Schnitt, glaube ich. Und das spielt natürlich noch eine ganz große Rolle. Das heißt, wir brauchen einen gewissen Treibhauseffekt, damit es für das Leben, für die Organismen angenehme Bedingungen hat und eben vor allem Wasser in allen drei Phasen vorkommt. Aber natürlich soll es nicht zu viel sein, dass uns hier nicht der Pelz anbrennt.
Wie viel näher müsste denn die Erde an die Sonne heranrücken, dass es sozusagen diese Kompensation gar nicht bräuchte?
Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, dürfte das etwa mit der Bahn der Venus der Fall sein. Also etwa 50 Millionen Kilometer näher an der Sonne würde.
Das heißt, wenn die Venus irgendwie in der Lage wäre, ihr CO2 abzupumpen, dann wäre alles super?
Ob alles super wäre, weiß ich nicht. Das Wasser ist ja schon weg. Das ist das Problem. Das heißt, aller Voraussicht nach ist im Inneren der Venus alles Wasser inzwischen ausgeschwitzt, sodass also diese Voraussetzungen nicht mehr da sind. Man könnte natürlich dann sagen, das Wasser könnte ja wieder durch Kometen auf die Venus kommen. Aber der Zug ist wahrscheinlich schon abgefahren, weil es einfach viel zu wenig Kometen, die mit den Körpern im inneren Sonnensystem kollidieren, gibt, die da noch Wasser abgeben können. Ein großer Teil oder man weiß nicht genau welcher Anteil, aber doch bestimmt ein signifikanter Anteil von Wasser, das wir auf der Erde haben, stammt nicht von der Erde selbst, sondern möglicherweise oder sehr wahrscheinlich von Kometen, die in der Frühzeit auf die Erde gestürzt sind und dort eben ihr Wasser abgeliefert haben. Tatsächlich so viel. Das ist ein bisschen umstritten, welcher Anteil das ist und wie wahrscheinlich das ist. Vor ein paar Jahren hat man noch gesagt, fast alles Wasser kommt aus der Erde selber. Inzwischen denkt man, dass doch ein ganz beträchtlicher Anteil von den Kometen kommen kann, die in den ersten 3, 4, 5, 6, 700 Millionen Jahren auf die Erde geprasselt sind, wie sich das Bombardement signifikant nachgelassen hat vor etwa 3,8 Milliarden Jahren.
Das heißt, so ganz so schlecht ist die Position der Erde dann auch wieder nicht. Man bewegt sich da quasi in so einen Bereich. Eigentlich wär es zu kalt, was den Abstand betrifft, aber die Erde ist in der Lage, die richtige Gasmischung vorzuhalten, um diesen Aufheizungseffekt zu erzeugen, der dadurch passiert, dass das Sonnenlicht auftrifft auf die Erde, aber dann nicht wieder rausgelassen wird.
So kann man es sicherlich ausdrücken. Es ist natürlich so, dass so ein System wie die Erde, nach meiner Einschätzung sind es einfach unglaublich viele kleine Stellschrauben, wo die Natur daran dreht und man eben nicht bis ins letzte Teil versteht, wie diese Stellschrauben miteinander verknüpft sind. Was es bedeutet, wenn man das eine festzurrt und an den anderen Schrauben dreht, was das für Effekte hat. Ich meine, dass bei der Diskussion, die wir gegenwärtig haben, über die Erwärmung der Erde spielt, das ja auch eine Rolle. Wir sind uns ziemlich sicher, dass der Mensch darauf einen Einfluss hat, aber wir können nach meinem Dafürhalten noch nicht ganz genau sagen, was es für Einflüsse hat, wenn beispielsweise wieder eine Periode mit mehr Vulkanausbrüchen kommt, wenn eine kleine Eiszeit kommt, von der man auch nicht so genau weiß, durch was sie eigentlich verursacht ist, wenn die Sonnenaktivität um ein bis zwei Prozent schwankt, weil die Sonnenflecken mal wieder weniger werden oder mal wieder sehr viel stärker werden. Das sind alles Freiheitsgrade, in denen wir uns bewegen, die einen Einfluss darauf haben, wo wir nicht genau wissen, wie das Ergebnis sein wird, meiner Meinung nach.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Venus und Erde gesprochen. Jetzt gibt es ja auch noch den Mars, der ja nun in den letzten Jahren auch als einer der meist erforschten Objekte im Sonnensystem gelten kann. Es gab zahlreiche Missionen. Man kurfte da die ganze Zeit mit Robotern drauf rum. Das ist ja schon fast eine Live-Übertragung. Wie steht denn der Mars im Verhältnis zu den anderen Nachbarn?
Na ja, man hat in den 70er Jahren durch die erste globale Kartierung und Charakterisierung des Mars, durch die beiden Vikings-Sonden der NASA eben festgestellt, dass der Mars doch der Planet ist, der der Erde am ähnlichsten ist. Das hören unsere Venusforscher natürlich überhaupt nicht gern. Die sagen natürlich, die Venus ist der erdähnlichste Planet. Aber das ist ein bisschen ein Streit um das Kaisersbad. Aber in der Tat sehen wir halt auf dem Mars viele Dinge, die uns sehr stark an die Erde erinnern. Als ein Wüstenplanet, auf dem es riesige Vulkane gibt, auf dem es Polkappen gibt, in denen ein bisschen Eis gebunden ist, auf dem wir Täler sehen, durch die vor Milliarden von Jahren Wasser geflossen sein muss. Und wir sehen tektonische Bruchstrukturen, wie wir sie von der Erde kennen. Also da spricht schon vieles dafür, dass der Mars eine ähnliche Charakteristik hat wie die Erde. Und dann stellt man sich eben die Frage, wenn er ähnlich ist, wie ähnlich ist er denn wirklich der Erde? Ist er so ähnlich, dass möglicherweise eben auch mal Leben auf dem Mars existierte oder vielleicht sogar heute noch existiert?
Ist er denn geologisch vergleichbar? Hat er auch so einen Eisenkern und auch Vulkanismus?
Er ist etwas, sag ich mal, einfacher gestrickt als die Erde, weil einfach die geologischen Prozesse mangelnd Masse nicht so in diesem Umfang abgelaufen sind wie auf der Erde. Das heißt, diese Umwälzungsprozesse durch Platten-Tektonik haben auf dem Mars Mars nicht stattgefunden. Es gibt ein paar Hinweise, dass in den ersten Milliarden Jahren, also vor etwa 4,2 bis 3,8 Milliarden Jahren, der Mars geologisch eine Art Platten-Tektonik ausgebildet hat, vielleicht auch ein kleines, schwaches Magnetfeld hatte, aber dann mangelnds Masse dieses Magnetfeld nicht aufrechterhalten konnte, vielleicht auch diese Ansätze von Platten-Tektonik nicht länger funktionierten. Aber der Mars hat beispielsweise einen lang andauernden, sehr intensiven Vulkanismus gehabt. Das lesen wir an diesen riesigen Vulkanen ab, die sich bis zu 24 Kilometer hoch aufgetürmt haben über permanenten Hotspots, also Quellen von Magma, das immer wieder nachgeliefert wurde und so eben diese riesigen Vulkanen erst möglich gemacht hat. Und wir sehen eben überall Spuren, die das Wasser auf der Oberfläche hinterlassen hat. Trockene Täler, die sich über Tausende von Kilometern durch das Marshochland winden, die sich dann in eine nördliche Tiefebene ergießen oder ergossen haben, wo möglicherweise vielleicht sogar mal ein kleiner Ozean oder ein großes stehendes Gewässer vorhanden war. Diese Dinge sehen wir. Und dann fragt man sich natürlich, wann war das und warum hat es aufgehört?
Dann müsste es ja eigentlich auch so eine Atmosphäre gegeben haben.
Es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass der Mars mal eine sehr viel dichtere und auch wärmere, dadurch ein Treibhauseffekt hatte und dadurch eben eine wärmere Atmosphäre hatte, aus der es vielleicht sogar auch mal regnete, also eine Art Wasserkreislauf hatte.
Aber wie soll denn sonst diese Kanäle entstanden sein, wenn da nicht immer wieder ein Kreislauf ist?
Es kann eben auch sein, dass Wasser unter der Oberfläche gespeichert ist in Hohlräumen, als Eis beispielsweise, und das Wasser taut dann ab und sickert aus dem Berg raus und bildet diese Flüssläufe. Das kann also auch sein. Aber es gibt eben in der Morphologie, also in der Oberflächenstruktur, dann schon Unterschiede, wie so Wasser abfließt, das abregnet und sich erst in kleinen Rinssalen sammelt, dann größere Bäche bildet, dann Flüsse, dann Ströme bildet. Also ein verästeltes...
So ein Sammelsystem.
Genau, ein drittisches System bildet. Das haben wir an manchen Stellen auf dem Mars auch entdeckt. Oder eben Täler, die ansatzlos irgendwo mitten im Gebirge, also in den Hochländern vom Mars anfangen und dann einfach abfließen, ohne dass es große Zuflüsse von den Seiten gibt.
Das würde also für diese unterirdische Versorgung sprechen, durch Auflösung des Eises durch das Magma.
Genau, das ist vermutlich eine Verbindung, eine Verknüpfung, die auf dem Mars sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass in Perioden, in denen der Vulkanismus aktiver war, eben so viel Wärme ausgestrahlt wurde in die Umgebung, dass dieses Eis in Hohlräumen schmolz und das Wasser dann abfließen konnte. Und dann die Hohlräume zum Beispiel nachgestürzt sind. Das sieht man dann an so Landschaften, die ganz chaotisch durcheinander gewürfelt sind, wo überall Hohlräume eingestürzt sind und einfach so eine Trümmerlandschaft zurückblieb. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo ist das ganze Wasser heute? Es gibt ja eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder es ist verdunstet, dann ist es in der Atmosphäre. Dort finden wir es heute nicht mehr, was kein Wunder ist, weil eben der Mars zu klein ist, diese dichte Wasseratmosphäre an sich zu binden und eben sicherlich sehr viel Wasser an die kosmische Umgebung abgegeben hat oder verloren hat. Oder es ist wiederum versickert dort, wo es am Ende von so einem Flusslauf sich in der Ebene irgendwie verbreitet hat, in den Untergrund, in Hohlräumen versickert und ist entweder dort heute noch vorhanden oder nicht mehr vorhanden.
Aber dass das Wasser dort jetzt noch gibt, das ist ja jetzt mittlerweile nachgewiesen worden.
Es gibt Wasser in Form von Eis in doch beträchtlicher Menge auf dem Mars, sehr viel mehr als man noch vor zehn Jahren angenommen hat. Hat man unter anderem mit Radargeräten ausfindig gemacht, hat man auch direkt nachweisen können, indem man in der Nähe vom Nordpol eine Sonde hat landen lassen. Die hat ein bisschen gekratzt und hat dann gleich unter der Oberfläche solche Raureiflächen entdeckt, die dann nach ein, zwei Tagen supplimiert sind, verdampft sind. Das Eis ist durchaus vorhanden und es ist sehr viel mehr, als man noch vor zehn Jahren gedacht hat.
Jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon herausgearbeitet, dass ja diese Monde der Gasplaneten doch sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten aufweisen zu den inneren Planeten des Sonnensystems. Inwiefern lassen sich denn jetzt... Also, wie schaut man jetzt auf diese Gemengelage, wenn man nicht alle paar Tage da eine neue Sonde starten kann? Welche Möglichkeiten hat man jetzt überhaupt, Erkenntnisse zu sammeln? Also wenn wir jetzt vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen auf den Kern der Arbeit des Instituts zurückkommen. Auf Basis welcher Erkenntnisse, auf Basis welcher Beobachtungen und Basis welcher Missionen und Instrumentarien kann man denn jetzt überhaupt vorankommen bei der Planetenforschung? Gibt es schon so viel Material, dass man eigentlich nur den ganzen Tag im Raum sitzt und denkt? Oder muss man sich mehr darum kümmern, voran das hinzukommen?
Das ist die Hoffnung, dass wir mal Zeit haben zum Nachdenken. Leider ist es meistens so, dass man in Daten ja nicht ersauft, aber doch üppig ausgestattet ist, wenn so eine Mission mal unterwegs ist. Und sich eher konzentrieren muss auf ganz wenige Fragestellungen, die man der Zeit, die einem zur Verfügung steht, bearbeiten kann. Also zunächst mal diese Ähnlichkeit zwischen den Planeten im inneren Sonnensystem und den Monden im äußeren Sonnensystem ist eine relative Ähnlichkeit. Es handelt sich bei den Monden im äußeren Sonnensystem zwar auch im Körper mit fester Oberfläche, aber eben auch einer überwiegend eisigen Oberfläche. Das heißt, dort ist die größte, die äußerste Kruste dieser Körper mehrere Zehner, vielleicht manchmal auch mehrere Hundert Kilometer, manchmal in einigen Fällen auch über 1000 Kilometer ein dicker Eispanzer. Erst dann kommt innen drin ein Gesteinskern beispielsweise. Weil einfach diese Verteilung flüchtiger Elemente, leichterere Elemente anders ist als im inneren Sonnensystem. Aber wo eben dann Ähnlichkeiten da sind, geologische Prozesse finden auch im äußeren Sonnensystem statt. Und das kann man eben wiederum untersuchen. Das heißt, man betrachtet beispielsweise die Eisoberfläche eines Jupiter-Mondes und guckt, wie viel Einschlagsgrader hat er, welche tektonischen Prozesse haben dort stattgefunden, wie wurde die Eisoberfläche gegebenenfalls überprägt durch Prozesse, die durch Wärme aus dem Inneren gesteuert wurden und kommt dann eben auch zu ganz interessanten Ergebnissen. Was die Frage mit dem Instrumentarium betrifft, gibt es da natürlich eben, wie wir ganz am Anfang mal festgestellt haben, durch den Faktor Entfernung zu Erde eben zu ganz unterschiedlichen Ansätzen. Also im äußeren Sonnensystem muss man einfach hoffen, dass man ein, zwei Missionen in seiner Lebensspanne aktiv mit begleiten kann. Und im inneren Sonnensystem hat man diese Gelegenheiten häufiger. Und im äußeren Sonnensystem waren es eben jetzt in meiner aktiven Zeit die Mission Galileo zum Jupiter und Cassini zum Saturn. Vor allem Cassini liefert unglaublich viele Ergebnisse.
Immer noch.
Wird bis 2017 noch weiterlaufen, weil sie so gut läuft. Und wo befindet sich die Sonne? Die umkreist den Saturn permanent und macht einen Nahvorbeiflug nach dem anderen, nutzt den Titan als Anker, um immer wieder die Bahn zu verändern und hat 13 Instrumente an Bord, die die unterschiedlichsten Fragestellungen beantworten. Und im Jupitersystem hat man eben durch Galileo eine ganze Menge neue Fragen aufgeworfen. Die Mission litt etwas darunter, dass die Antenne sich nicht entfaltete und nur 12 Prozent der Daten zur Erde kamen. Das war von 1995 bis 2002. Und hat sich natürlich jetzt inzwischen wieder Gedanken gemacht, dass man dort unbedingt wieder hin muss, weil man im Jupitersystem aus Sicht der Planetengeologie und aus Sicht der Frage, wo vielleicht Nischen für Leben im Sonnensystem vorhanden sind, ein wenig sogar zwei ganz interessante Körber eben dort vorhanden sind. Das eine ist der Eismond Ganymede. Das ist der größte Mond im Sonnensystem. Der hat unter seiner Eiskruste vermutlich ein Reservoir an Wasser. Aber noch viel mehr vermutlich der Eismond Europa, der eine sehr junge Oberfläche hat. Vermutlich nur eine relativ dünne Eiskruste. Und unter dieser Eiskruste ein vielleicht 200 Kilometer, die Schätzungen gehen von 80 bis 200 Kilometern, mächtigen Ozean hat. Und dieser Ozean hat an seiner Untergrenze Kontakt zu dem Mantel dieses Mondes, zum Gesteinsmantel. Und wird vermutlich, weil er ein bisschen warm ist, aufgrund der Druck- und Temperaturbedingungen hat er die Möglichkeit, aus diesem Gesteinsmantel Minerale rauszulösen, sodass es sich um mineralisches, mineralisch angereichertes Wasser handelt. Also kein Mineralwasser.
Wodurch entsteht die Wärme an der Stelle? Ist das dann einfach die Gravitation des Jupiter, der permanent an diesem Mond reist?
Ganz genau, das ist eine interessante Geschichte. Zum einen ist der Jupiter mit seiner unglaublichen Masse, zieht auf der einen Seite, und auf der anderen Seite steht diese Europa eben in einer Resonanz mit seinen beiden nächsten Planeten, das heißt mit Ganymed und mit Io im Inneren, sodass praktisch die drei Monde immer wieder wie in einer Perlenschnur aufgereiht in einer Reihe sind und dadurch sich praktisch Gezeitenkräfte entwickeln, die Verreibung innerhalb dieses Körpers sorgen und dadurch Wärme erzeugen. Jetzt gibt es unterschiedliche Modelle, ob die Wärme ausreicht, einen Ozean permanent praktisch flüssig zu halten unter dieser Eiskruste, oder ob der irgendwann mal ausgefroren ist und dann nicht wieder erwärmt werden konnte, sodass er wieder geschmolzen wäre. Aber weil eben dieser Mond an seiner Oberfläche fast keine Einschlagsgrader zeigt, scheint es der Fall zu sein, dass diese Oberfläche ganz jung ist. Sie ist deswegen eben ganz jung, weil immer wieder durch Brüche in der Kruste von Europa Wasser an die Oberfläche trinkt. Das nennt man Eisvulkanismus, oder wir nennen es eben Kryovulkanismus. Und dadurch die Oberfläche überprägt ist und uns dadurch anzeigt, dass im Inneren noch was los ist gewissermaßen. Und das ist jetzt so der Traum aller Planetenforscher, dass man da mal hinfliegt, auf der Oberfläche landet und mit einem heißen Bohrer durch die Eiskruste durchpobelt und ein U-Boot in diesem Ozean aussetzt und praktisch guckt, ob einem da was entgegenschwimmt. Also vereinfacht ausgedrückt. Das ist noch in weiter Ferne.
Aber da muss man ja richtig tief bohren.
Vermutlich muss man gar nicht so tief bohren an den Nahtstellen, wo dieses Wasser immer wieder über die Oberfläche schwappt. Das scheint also an diesen tektonischen... Es scheint also tektonische Bruchstrukturen zu geben, wo möglicherweise, so ähnlich wie bei unseren mittel-ozeanischen Rücken, wo das Magma an die Ozeanboden-Oberfläche quillt, dass es dort ganz dünn ist. Wie dünn lässt sich noch nicht abschätzen. Aber deshalb wird eben als nächster Schritt jetzt mal eine intensive Erkundung von Europa aus der Umlaufbahn geplant. Und das wird eine große europäisch-amerikanische Mission sein, die Anfang der 20er-Jahre vermutlich starten wird.
Hattest du schon einen Namen?
EJSM Europa-Jupiter... Ah, ich krieg's nicht zusammen.
Noch keinen richtigen catchy Name, den man sich sofort nennen würde. Aber es geht im Prinzip dann um einen Ersatz dieser Galileo-Mission.
Europa-Jupiter-System-Mission heißt sie.
Das heißt, man muss ja erst mal gucken, wo sind diese Bruchstellen? Und dann kann man darüber nachdenken, eine zweite Mission in der Herze schicken? Oder würde man das Teil dann gleich mit so einem Bohrer da hinschicken?
Das wird noch ohne Bohrer sein. Und man muss sich immer vor Augen halten, das ist gerade bei Missionen ins äußere Sonnensystem extrem große, aufwendige Projekte sind, die ganz lang vorbereitet werden müssen und natürlich dann auch entsprechend teuer sind. Und dann möchte man dann auch keinen Failschlag. Und es ist dann schon schwierig, praktisch dann das Nachfolgeprojekt schon im Auge zu haben, so gern man das hätte. Die Planung dauert zehn Jahre, der Flug dorthin vier bis fünf Jahre, das Datensammeln fünf Jahre und schon ist ein halbes Forscherleben vorbei. Also bei Cassini, als da jetzt die Mission bis 2017 beschlossen wurde, haben die Wissenschaftler gesagt, sie möchten dann aber auch bitte Forschungsgelder, um sich alle Rollstühle kaufen zu können, weil sie dann alle 70 Jahre alt sind. Die erste Idee zu dieser Mission kommt aus den 80er-Jahren. Anfangen der 80er-Jahre. Cassini wurde in den 80er-Jahren geplant. 1996, 1997 startete sie dann. Und dann 2004 kam sie an und geht jetzt bis 2017. Und das macht natürlich die Sache schwierig für so ein Forscherleben. Bei dem Mars und auf dem Mond und im Inneren in so einem System ist das zum Glück etwas einfacher.
Das heißt, kurz gesagt, wir hatten ja über Planetenforschung sozusagen die Tätigkeit gesprochen, Daten gibt es genug. Man muss nur schauen, was man da eigentlich für sich urba macht, beziehungsweise welche Forschungsziele man sich konkret setzt. Was steht denn so im Mittelpunkt eigentlich? Ist die Frage nach dieser Lebensentstehung der Kern? Hat man schon genug über Planeten an sich insgesamt gesammelt, dass man sich jetzt darauf konzentriert? Es gibt ja da auch eine Initiative, die sich im Wesentlichen darauf konzentriert.
Wir verwenden oft so ein Bild dafür, dass wir sagen, die Raumfahrt ist jetzt etwas mehr als 50 Jahre alt. Wenn man sieht, was man in diesen 50 Jahren alles erreicht hat, ist schon ganz enorm, was wir über unsere benachbarten Himmelskörper wissen, unsere unmittelbare kosmische Nachbarschaft. Trotzdem waren diese ersten 50 Jahre mehr ein Entdecken. Und jetzt beginnt mehr das Erforschen. Oder man kann es vielleicht auch noch mal in einem anderen Bild zusammenfassen. Bisher war alles Küstenschiffert, so wie Magellan an der Küste Südamerikas entlang gesegelt ist und Karten von der Küstenlinie gemacht hat. Und irgendwann mal muss man natürlich den Mut zusammennehmen und sagen, so, jetzt fahren wir auch mal den Amazonas hoch und gucken, wo der Indianer sitzt. Und so an dieser Schnittstelle sind wir vielleicht jetzt, sodass man jetzt genau oder besser weiß, was man wissen will auf der Grundlage dessen, was man jetzt schon entdeckt hat. Dass man hat ein sehr genaues Bild von der Oberfläche des Mars, des Mondes, auch der Venus. Und damit haben sich neue Fragen aufgetan, die eben ganz oft damit zu tun haben, dass wir eben erkunden wollen, ob das Leben auf der Erde einmalig ist oder es Nischen gibt allein schon auf unseren Nachbarplaneten, wo das auch möglich ist. Aber natürlich viele, viele andere Fragen auch noch. Wie haben sich die Planeten in diesen viereinhalb Milliarden Jahren entwickelt? Was bedeutet das für die Frühgeschichte der Erde? Welches Schicksal wird unser Sonnensystem überhaupt nehmen? Welche Möglichkeiten haben wir, mal auf andere Himmelskörper zu gehen? Die halte ich für relativ gering. Entfernungen sind einfach groß. Und so ist jetzt eigentlich eine ganz spannende Phase angebrochen. Es ist, wie in einem der vorherigen Beiträge auch schon sehr schön geschildert worden ist, bei der Planung der Mission Rosetta beispielsweise. Da fliegt man zu einem Kometen. Und das macht man ja nicht einfach so, weil man sagt, so, jetzt lass uns mal zu einem Kometen fliegen, sondern all diese Missionen, die ja auch sehr viel Geld kosten, werden vorbereitet unter der Prämisse, welche Fragen sind noch offen? Welche Daten brauchen wir noch? Welche Instrumente brauchen wir da dafür? Und was wollen wir für Ergebnisse erzielen? Und so ist es natürlich richtig. Es sind viele Missionen zum Mars geflogen. Jede hatte eine andere Fragestellung. Jede hatte andere Experimente dabei. Und so baut eins auf dem anderen auf. Und gerade bei Mars zum Beispiel sind wir jetzt in so einer interessanten Schnittstelle, dass man den Planeten so gut kartiert hat wie keinen anderen Planeten im Sonnensystem. Vielleicht sogar noch besser als die Erde. Wenn man bedenkt, dass viele Ozeanböden bei uns überhaupt nicht genau bekannt sind. Und jetzt kommt man eben an den Punkt, wo man sagt, wo wollen wir landen, wenn wir wirklich gezielt nach Wasser und nach Leben suchen wollen. Oder nach Spuren früheren Lebens. Und da ist noch keine Einigkeit. Man hat Ideen, man hat Vorschläge. Klar, man sieht die Spuren, wo das Wasser geflossen ist. Aber versucht es jetzt eben noch besser einzugrenzen, indem man eben ganz genau sich überlegt, wo ist das Wasser vielleicht heute noch vorhanden im Untergrund, weil ein Vulkan in der Nähe ist. Weil so viele Schüsse hat man nicht. Allein schon als Geldkunden.
Und Zeitkunden auch.
Und Zeitkunden.
Aber sozusagen der Maß ist eigentlich so... Man hat sozusagen die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben, dass man auf dem Mars tatsächlich noch was findet, was man als Leben bezeichnen könnte. Oder ist das irgendwie ausgeschlossen?
Ich würde es nicht mit dem Begriff Hoffnung verknüpfen. Ich würde es einfach an den Tatsachen festmachen, die wir dort sehen. Und dadurch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, auf dem Mars in unserem Sonnensystem Leben zu finden. Also vermutlich Leben, das früher existiert hat. Weniger wahrscheinlich Leben, das heute noch existiert. Das ist auf dem Mars eben am größten. Aber es gibt eben auch diese exotischen Körper im äußeren Sonnensystem, die man nicht abschreiben soll. Und vielleicht Generationen nach uns sagen wir, Mensch, es ist doch ganz klar, dass man eigentlich dort hätte suchen müssen.
Also die Jupiter, Saturn, Monde etc. Die aber halt weit weg sind. Was ja ein großes Thema war, finde ich zumindest so in der letzten Zeit oder was jetzt irgendwie zum großen Thema aufkommt, wir haben es schon teilweise angedeutet, auch im Einstieg, ist halt sozusagen die Forschung nach Planeten außerhalb unseres Sonnensystems. Du hast ja schon angesprochen, es gibt zwei neue Methoden, die jetzt besonders viel Erfolg gehabt haben, um Planeten zu entdecken, die man so erstmal vielleicht gar nicht sehen kann oder meistens nicht sehen kann, weil selbst wenn die Teleskope bis dahin reichen würden, dahin zu schauen, man dann immer noch eine Sonne in der Nähe hat, die einfach so hell strahlt, dass es einen blendet. Welche Methoden sind denn das, die da so erfolgreich waren?
Ja, genau, das größte Problem ist, dass der Stern so hell ist. Das heißt, wenn dort ein Planet von der Größe der Erde um einen Stern, der jetzt, sag ich mal, 10 Lichtjahre, 100 Lichtjahre entfernt ist und vor diesem Stern vorbeizieht, dann kann das kein Teleskop auflösen. Aber man hat eben Instrumente entwickelt, die können, wenn so ein Planet genau in der Sichtlinie zwischen Stern und Beobachtungsteleskop vor diesem Stern vorbeizieht, also ihn umkreist, dann können diese Instrumente den Lichtabfall, der dadurch erzeugt wird, aufzeichnen. Das ist in etwa vergleichbar, wenn man nachts in tiefster dunkler Nacht auf eine Straßenlaterne guckt und sieht, da sind kleine Mücken, die dort vorbeifliegen dauernd. Und wenn so eine Mücke vor so einer Straßenlaterne vorbeifliegt, verdunkelt sie das Licht auch um einen winzigen Bruchteil eines Prozents. Und das kann man eben nachmessen. Und wenn das periodisch immer wieder geschieht am gleichen Stern, dann ist man sich ziemlich sicher, oder kann sehr sicher sein, dass dieser Stern von einem Planeten umkreist wird. Der Nachteil dieser Methode ist, wenn dieser Planet nicht in dieser Ebene den Planeten, die die Sonne umkreist, in der ich mit meinem Teleskop blicke, dann sehe ich ihn nie. Wenn der senkrecht zu der Ebene kreist, dann werde ich da gar nichts sehen. Da kann es dann aber dafür sein, wenn das ein relativ großer Planet ist und der relativ nahe ist an seinem Stern, dass er an diesem auch ein bisschen zieht. Die Gesetze der Schwerkraft sind eben so, dass eben nicht nur das Große am Kleinen zieht, sondern auch das Kleine ein bisschen am Großen zieht.
Das heißt, die Sonne eiert?
Die Sonne eiert ein bisschen. Das heißt, das Licht, das dieser Stern, diese Sonne aussendet, wird einmal ein bisschen gedehnt im Sinne des Dopplereffekts. Also das Licht wird ein bisschen röter. Und wenn es auf einen zukommt, das Objekt, dann wird es ein bisschen blauer. Dieses Wobbling, diese Eierei, die kann ich dann gegebenenfalls auch aufzeichnen. Mit den beiden Methoden hat man die meisten, ich glaube, 500 sind es vielleicht schon, vor wenigen Wochen waren es noch unter 500 Exoplaneten entdeckt.
Und das innerhalb der letzten wie viel Jahre?
15 Jahre.
Das heißt, vor 15 Jahren hat man das erste Mal einen entdeckt. Und das auch schon auf Basis dieser Methoden?
Genau. Und teleskopisch werden wir noch viele Jahre brauchen, bis wir den ersten Planeten wirklich als solches auflösen können. Es gibt jetzt die ersten Sternplanetensysteme, wo man das ansatzweise auflösen könnte. Aber bis man das richtig kann, dass man das gegebenenfalls sogar vortholz von so einem Planeten machen könnte, das werden wir nicht mehr erleben.
Geht das dann nur von der Erde aus, oder geht das nur aus dem All heraus?
Also wir haben beispielsweise jetzt einige Entdeckungen gemacht mit einem Teleskop, das die Erde umkreist, weil dort einfach die störende Atmosphäre nicht da ist. Dieses Teleskop heißt COROT und wird von der französischen Weltraumagentur betrieben. Wir arbeiten da sehr intensiv mit und haben da jetzt einige sehr schöne Entdeckungen gemacht. Wie bei allem bekommt man gleich Appetit auf mehr, sodass also jetzt in einer Ausschreibung der ESA geht es auch darum, ob möglicherweise eine Nachfolgemission von Coro auf ESA-Ebene betrieben wird. Die heißt dann PLATO und soll sich eben auch mit der Durchmusterung des Nachthimmels aus der Erdumlaufbahn beschäftigen. Dort möglicherweise ganz, ganz viele Exoplaneten entdecken.
Und was, also wie weit, wenn es jetzt 500, 500, 500 Exoplaneten gibt, ist das gesichert oder ist das Vermutung?
Die sind ziemlich gut gesichert.
Und wie weit ist sozusagen der nächste entfernt?
Ich glaube, der nächste, den man entdeckt hat, ist zehn Lichtjahre entfernt. Das ist schon verdammt nah, wenn man so möchte. Der nächste Stern von der Erde ist ja gerade mal zweieinhalb Lichtjahre entfernt. Vier und halb Lichtjahre entfernt. Und soviel zehn Lichtjahre, also praktisch um die Ecke ja schon eigentlich. Und was uns im Umkehrschluss natürlich auch wieder...
Welches Stern gehört das dann?
Das weiß ich nicht auswendig. Aber es bedeutet eben im Umkehrschluss, dass das All, allein unsere Galaxie, die Milchstraße, möglicherweise voll von diesen Dingern ist. Und man hat ja bisher aufgrund der Beobachtungsmethode eben hauptsächlich Planeten, Exoplaneten entdeckt, die entweder sehr nah an ihrem Stern dran sind und oder sehr groß sind, also Jupiter-großes Objekte sind. Und vermutlich ist es einfach nur der Beobachtungsmethode geschuldet, dass wir die Kleinen noch nicht erwischen können. Das heißt, das wird dann der nächste Schritt sein, dass man sagt, okay, das sind jetzt über 90 Prozent dieser Körper, die wir entdeckt haben, sind Jupiter-ähnliche Planeten. Und vielleicht gibt es aber genauso viele erdähnliche Planeten, können sie nur noch nicht entdecken. Und das wäre vermutlich jetzt die Aufgabe der nächsten 10 Jahre, diesen Nachweis zu führen.
Kann man denn davon ausgehen, dass es, wenn es etwas Jupiter-ähnliches gibt, dass es eigentlich auch zwangsläufig etwas, zumindest Mars-Erdemäßiges geben muss, weil das ja aus einer Scheibe oben eine Sonne hervorgegangen ist, die sich eben erstmal gleichmäßig über die gesamte Länge erstreckt hat und dann haben sich irgendwo Planeten gefunden. Dann müssten ja sozusagen...
Ganz genau.
So ist das.
Das gibt zumindest, also nicht ganz eine Handvoll Planeten, von denen man annimmt, dass sie schon erdähnliche Charakteristika haben, also vielleicht eine feste Oberfläche, aber möglicherweise ganz heiß sind noch, also nicht die Voraussetzungen bieten, wie wir sie auf der Erde haben. Vor kurzem wurde eine Beobachtung...
Also die wir derzeit auf der Erde haben, aber wir schon irgendwann mal hatten auf der Erde.
Ja, also beispielsweise eine feste Oberfläche und Ozeane, das kann man noch nicht nachweisen. Vor kurzem wurde eine Entdeckung aus Amerika berichtet, die sagen, das ist ein Planet, der möglicherweise seinen Stern in einer gebundenen Rotation umkreist, wie wir es vorhin auch schon mal angedeutet haben. Also wie der Mond um die Erde. Genau, und zwar allerdings auf der Seite, die das dem Stern zuweist, sehr heiß ist, auf der anderen Seite sehr kalt ist, aber möglicherweise in der Tag- und Nachtgrenze die Temperaturen so sind, dass dort Wasser stabil sein könnte. Die Beobachtung wird ein bisschen kritisch betrachtet. Die Daten lassen auch andere Interpretationen zu, sodass man da so ein bisschen vorsichtiger geworden ist. Aber man erkennt eben, dass mit jeder neuen Entdeckung die Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt immer größer wird, dass man so einen erdähnlichen Planeten irgendwann mal entdecken wird. Ob der dann so aussieht, ist eine ganz andere Frage. Mit den Antriebssystemen, die wir zurzeit haben, sicherlich nicht. Ich mach immer gerne ein Spiel mit Schulklassen, wenn sie da sind. Die fragen, wo fliegt man da hin und wie fliegt man da hin und wann landen wir auf dem Mars und wann landen wir auf dem Jupiter usw. Einfach mal die ganz banale Rechnung zu machen. Ein Licht verlegt in einer Sekunde 300.000 Kilometer zurück. Ein Jahr hat 365 mal 24, mal 60, mal 60 Sekunden. Und das mal 300.000. Und dann ausrechnen 4,5 Lichtjahre sind es zum nächsten Stern. Und dann das Dividieren durch die Geschwindigkeit, die ein Raumschiff zur Zeit eben fliegt. Das sagt man einfach mal 50.000 Stundenkilometer. Das ist schon ziemlich schnell. Das schafft eigentlich kein Raumschiff. Und dann kommt so eine Antwort, das sind ja über 10.000 Jahre. Das kann ja nicht sein. Und doch genau ist es eben so. Es sind dann einfach mehrere tausend Jahre, bis wir mit unseren heutigen Methoden der Raumfahrt irgendwo ankommen. Und das heißt noch lange nicht, dass es dort gemütlich ist.
Ja, geschweige denn, dass man sich auch nur im Ansatz in der Lage sehen würde, irgendwas zu bauen, von dem man sicher sagen kann, dass es so viele tausend Jahre auch hält.
Genau.
Obweier. Das ist eigentlich schade. Hofft man dann doch noch mal so auf Wurmlöcher und irgendwelche kosmischen Aufzüge?
Ja, das übersteigt mein Vorstellungsvermögen fast vollständig.
Ja, ach, das ist ja hier wirklich auch ein unendliches Thema. Jetzt haben wir schon sehr lange darüber geredet. Haben wir denn irgendwas ganz Wichtiges, was in so einem Überblick erwähnt werden sollte, noch ausgelassen?
Was ich ganz interessant finde und was auch in den letzten Jahren sehr aktiv betrieben worden ist, ist die Mondforschung. Das ist eigentlich etwas, wo ich auch angefangen habe. Und man ist in den letzten Jahren doch fast bei allen raumfadtreibenden Nationen darauf gekommen, dass man auf dem Mond noch eine ganze Menge interessante Forschung betreiben kann, vor allem auch deswegen, weil er so nah ist.
Der ist ja auch so ein bisschen rausgefallen, nachdem er am Anfang fleißig drauf rumgeturnt ist.
Genau, da war so ein bisschen die Luft raus nach Apollo, weil es waren unglaublich viele Daten und Messungen da. Dann hat man das alles ausgewertet und hat dadurch für die Erde sehr viele interessante Fragen beantworten können. Für das innere Sonnensystem, für die Frühzeit des Sonnensystems, weil wir diese alte Oberfläche auf dem Mond sehen. Und hat jetzt eben festgestellt, dass dort noch eine ganze Menge interessanter Fragen zu beantworten sind und dass man das auch relativ leicht machen kann. Insbesondere die aufstrebenden Raumfahrtnationen sind da sehr aktiv, wie Indien und China. Die Japaner sowieso, die haben eine ganz großartige Mondmission gehabt vor ein paar Jahren. Und die Amerikaner sind jetzt auch mit einer fantastischen Sünde wieder am Mond. Und das eben auch viele Raumfahrtunternehmungen, die man vielleicht für die nächsten 50 Jahre......wenn du siehst. Wir haben jetzt auch ein ganzes Thema, das ist die Umgebung. Wir haben jetzt auch ein ganzes Thema, das ist die Umgebung. Das ist die Umgebung, die wir in unserem Lebensabschnitt auch noch mal vorkommen wird. Was heißt Sprungbrett?
Die ganze Material akkumuliert und dann da oben zusammenbaut und dann noch mal startet, weil man weniger Treibstoff braucht?
Weil man einfach viel zu viel Energie bräuchte, um von der Erde direkt zu starten oder aus der Erdumlaufbahn zu starten.
Das heißt, man verteilt es dann quasi auf mehrere Missionen und baut sich was zusammen.
Dann ist der Mond eben ein ideales Physiklabor. Man kann dort viele Experimente eben in völlig keimfreier Umgebung ausführen. Man kann Astrophysik machen, man kann Radio Physik machen, Radioastronomie machen, solche Dinge. Also der Mond ist nach wie vor hochgradig spannend. Man möchte jetzt noch nicht so weit gehen, dass wie in einem Bestseller neulich oder vor kurz vor einem Jahr etwa gesagt wurde, dass der Mond unbedingt mal als Lagerstätte ausgebeutet werden müsste, um dort Helium-3 abzubauen, das sich dort angereichert hat. Soweit ist man sicherlich noch nicht, aber vielleicht in 500 Jahren. Und wer vor 100 Jahren gesagt hätte, in 1969 wird jemand auf dem Mond stehen, dann hätte man ja ziemlich sicher damals in die Klapse geschickt. Wer weiß, was in 500 Jahren ist.
Das war, glaube ich, auch 10 Jahre, bevor es jemand auf dem Mond gab, noch nicht so greifbar. Von daher hat man eh den Eindruck, dass sich die Sachen da beschleunigen. Aber was ist an diesen Missionen, die da jetzt geplant sind und gerade gelaufen sind, so großartig und so fantastisch? Also was macht das da aus?
Also zunächst mal wurde dadurch der Mond völlig neu kartiert. Das heißt, die ganzen Daten...
Durch die Mission der Japaner vor allem?
Durch die Mission der Amerikaner jetzt vor allem. Die Datengrundlage, mit der wir heute noch Mondforschung betreiben, in dem Raum, wo wir hier diese Aufzeichnung gerade machen, in diesen ganzen Schränken hier, sind Mondaufnahmen aus den 60er-Jahren. Und oft mit denen arbeiten wir noch, weil sie zum einen ausgezeichnet waren, aber es ist eben der Stand der Forschung gewesen. Und man hat seither keine besseren Daten gewonnen. Und jetzt erst ist man auf die Idee gekommen oder setzt um, dass man endlich wieder globale Datensätze vom Mond anfertigt, in verschiedenen Wellenlängen und in verschiedenen Bildauflösungen und verschiedenen Spektralkanälen, um die Mineralologie des Mondes besser herauszubekommen. Man sieht, dass der Mond doch sehr viel vielseitiger in seiner Geologie ist, als man noch vor 10, 20 Jahren angenommen hat, dass möglicherweise die Prozesse, die im Inneren abgelaufen sind, sehr viel länger angedauert haben, als man früher dachte, dass der Mond keineswegs nach einer Milliarde Jahre bereits geologisch tot war, sondern der Vulkanismus länger angedauert hat. Eine ganze Menge dieser Fragen sind interessant. Und mit das Spannendste war sicherlich letztes Jahr oder die letzten zwei Jahre die Beobachtung, dass auf dem Mond Wasser in Form von Eis zum Teil vorhanden ist, ist eben in diesen Löchern am Süd- und Nordpol, diesen Einschlagsgrad, wo nie Licht hintrinkt. Oder eben auch zum Teil im Mond Staub durch Kometen dorthin gebracht und unter der Oberfläche vor der Sublimation geschützt. Also das eröffnet auch neue Möglichkeiten vielleicht für die permanente, ich sage jetzt mal nicht Besiedlung des Mondes, aber statt Raumstationen in der Erdumlaufbahn sind auch Mondstationen möglich. Wenn der Mond natürlich ein Problem immer bestehen bleibt, dadurch, dass er sich in 28 Tagen einmal um sich selber dreht, heißt das 14 Tage dunkel, 14 Tage hell. 14 Tage hell ist soweit kein Problem, aber die 14 Tage dunkel kann ich keinen Strom erzeugen mit Sonnensegeln und dieses Problem muss man erst mal in Griff bekommen mit Batterien. Ja, das ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte.
Wenn da eh das Wasser ist, müsste man da nicht...
Jaja, es gibt am Pol Krateränder, die heißen dann auch Peak of Eternal Light, also der Gipfel des ewigen Lichts, weil die Rotation des Mondes senkrecht auf seiner Bahn erfolgt und dadurch eben dieser Kraterrend sich praktisch permanent dem Sonnenlicht ausgesetzt zieht, wäre das ein ganz interessantes Ziel dort zu landen. Aber ich muss dort erst mal landen können.
Senkrecht zu seiner Bahn oder senkrecht zur Sonne? So seiner Rotationsachse.
Und die Rotationsachse ist senkrecht auf der Bahn.
Zur Sonne.
Ja.
Das heißt anders als die Erde, die ja leicht gekippt ist.
So ist es, ja. Und dort zu landen ist natürlich total spannend, weil man könnte da mit einem Rauwe oder irgendeinem Fahrzeug oder Roboter eben in dieses Kraterinnere runterfahren und das Eis dort abbauen oder zumindest mal analysieren. Aber erstens sind die topografischen Modelle dieser Umgebung noch nicht hinreichend genau, jetzt wird's besser eben, jetzt kommen die Daten. Und man hat sowas halt raumfahrtechnisch noch nie gemacht.
Jetzt kommen die Daten durch zukünftige Missionen oder durch laufende Missionen?
Durch die laufende Missionen und dann vielleicht...
Welche Missionen sind das, die da gerade so...
Also im Moment die aktive amerikanische Mission, die heißt Luna Reconnaissance Orbiter. Die hat also fantastische Kameras an Bord und auch ein Laser-Höhenmesser, der also sehr genaue Höhenprofile vom Mond erzeugt. Und die Chinesen sind gerade mit ihrem 2. Orbiter am Mond. Da erfährt man allerdings nicht so arg viel, wie die Daten sind. Sie sind aber nach allem, was man so hört, sehr gut. Die können das. Und der nächste Schritt wird sicherlich sein, in der Nähe des Südpols mal zu landen. Das planen die Europäer, das planen die Amerikaner, das planen die Chinesen wahrscheinlich auch. Und dann wird man sehen, was daraus wird.
Warum kriegt man bei der chinesischen Mission jetzt nicht so viel mit? Teilen die ihre Informationen nicht mit der restlichen Wissenschaftsgemeinde?
So ist es, ja. Das ist vermutlich unter stark militärischem Einfluss dort. Und die Daten werden zunächst mal unumdeckel gehalten.
Aber das wird nicht unbedingt auf Ewigkeiten so bleiben?
Glauben wir nicht. Also Wissenschaft ist grenzenlos, denke ich mal.
Sollte sie zumindest sein. Welche Missionen planen die Europäer dann konkret?
Ja, die ESA plant eine Mondlandemission, da ist aber noch nicht klar, wo sie genau landen soll. Das ist aber ein Projekt, das in diesem Jahrzehnt wahrscheinlich eingegangen wird. Und bei der NASA ist ein Projekt, das heißt Moonrise im Gespräch, das nächstes Jahr vielleicht entschieden wird, wo eine Sonde auf der erdaabgewandten Seite des Mondes in einem tiefen Einschlagsbecken landen soll. Das ist also das größte Einschlagsbecken, das es im Sonnensystem gibt. Und das hat die Mondkrüste so tief angekratzt, dass man dort möglicherweise auf Mantelgestein treffen kann und dort Proben nehmen könnte, die man noch nirgendswo im Sonnensystem so genommen hat. Ganz ursprüngliches Mantelmaterial eines erdähnlichen Körpers.
Also noch nicht mal auf der Erde.
Genau. Und die möchten das eben zur Erde zurückbringen mit einer Kapsel, die dann vom Mond wieder zurückstartet. Automatisch und unbemannt.
Dann wird ja sozusagen der frühe Science-Fiction mit Mondbasen etc. durchaus noch Realität.
Ja, es ist sicherlich noch ein weiter Schritt bis dahin. Und die Frage ist natürlich immer, wie sinnvoll ist es, Menschen permanent dieser Gefahr auszusetzen, der kosmischen Umgebung. Und da hat die Astronautik sicherlich auch noch viele, viele Fragen, die sie klären muss.
Ja, oder ich denke, jetzt haben wir es erst mal ganz gut hier in Überblick geschafft. War auch keine kurze Sendung. Oder gibt es noch irgendeine dringende Botschaft an die Welt?
Es gibt hunderttausende von kleinen Aspekten, die unheimlich interessant sind. Also was ich gerne der Welt mitteilen möchte, ist, dass es ein unglaublich faszinierendes Forschungsfeld ist, wo wir uns nie langweilen, weil es eben so vielseitig ist, ganz viele verschiedene Aspekte der Naturwissenschaften beinhaltet. Und wenn man es großzügig sieht, oder muss man eigentlich nicht großzügig sehen, dann muss man auch sagen, es geht eigentlich über das Naturwissenschaftliche hinaus. Wenn man sich diese Frage nach der Suche von Leben überlegt, das ist eine der Urfragen der Menschheit, das Philosophische schon berührt, ohne dass ich jetzt behaupten will, dass ich ein Philosoph bin. Aber es ist etwas, das macht einem schon manchmal ein bisschen gribbeln. Und ich finde es unheimlich toll, dass man an solchen Projekten mitarbeiten kann. Und wir hier im Institut ebenso in vielen verschiedenen Projekten gleichzeitig sind. Man bekommt von allen möglichen Missionen was mit. Wir sind an der Venus, mit Venus Express, dann die Schwester-Sonde ist Mars Express, auch von der ESA. Dann ist die ESA-Sonde Rosetta auf dem Weg zum Kometen. Da freuen wir uns jetzt schon, wenn die 2014 ankommt, dann 2015 zum ersten Mal auf dem Kometen landen wird. Die amerikanische Raumsonde Dawn, wo eine Kamera von uns mit drauf ist, die wir zusammen mit Max Planck entwickelt haben, die kommt nächstes Jahr am Asteroiden Vesta an und dann fliegt sie weiter zu Ceres. Dann Cassini läuft noch und dann wird es wieder irgendwann zum Jupiter gehen. Dann Messenger kommt nächstes Jahr am Merkur an. Man bräuchte 48-Stunden-Tage, um all das zu verarbeiten, was hier die verschiedenen Kollegen machen und kann überall neugierig reinhören und kriegt da ganz viel mit.
Über welche Ausbildungswege stößt man denn so in die Planetenforschung am besten? Also Geologen sind hier auf jeden Fall gefragt.
Geologie, Physik, Chemie, seit neuestem auch Biologie eben, durch den Zweig der Exobiologie, dann natürlich die Ingenieurwissenschaften, die dann mehr, sag ich mal, in Instrumenten und Experimente entwickeln, beteiligt sind und gibt eigentlich keine Grenzen. Man braucht Mathematiker für Bahnberechnungen. Querbeet. Geografie natürlich, also für Geodesie-Überlegungen, also dass man Karpenwerke anfertigen kann. Natürlich alles mit ganz neuen Methoden als noch vor 50 Jahren, als man also praktisch in der Planetengeodesie am Anfang war, aber heute ganz komplexe dreidimensionale Modellierungen. Selbst der unförmigsten Körper im Asteroidengürtel machen kann. Eine Kunst, die mir auf ewig verschlossen sein wird, wie die das hinbekommen, aber es ist unheimlich toll.
Gut, dann denke ich, machen wir hier erst mal einen Punkt. Da sind sicherlich zahlreiche Themen drin, die man dann im Einzelnen später hier auch noch mal aufnehmen kann. Aber soweit bedanke ich mich erst mal für die Ausführung.
Ja, hat mich sehr gefreut.
Und ja, auch danke wieder fürs Zuhören bei dieser noch etwas länger geratenen Sendung als sonst. Aber so soll es sein, ausführlich und bloß nichts Spannendes auslassen. Auch wenn wir jetzt viel Spannendes natürlich wieder ausgelassen haben. Ja, und das war's. Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören. Schaut wieder rein, wenn es hier wieder heißt. Gut, Raumzeit, bis bald.